on salue fab salut à tous enfin bon on a
lancé le stream
on n'est sûr de rien mais on n'est plus
sûr de rien enfin on était sûr mais on
n'est plus sûr voilà donc à temps je
vais je vais je vais jeter un oeil sur
avec avec mon mobile parce que je ne
suis pas à tancer passé tout à l'heure
prévue
attends attends attends tu entends je
crois que là je crois que là on est bon
là à cerner vos attentes à 18 heures
wayne il commençait à 18 heures mais le
truc c'est que depuis hier il ya des
bugs sur twitch et je me demande si si
si c'est pas pour ça que j'ai réussi pas
à voir ouais je comprends rien mais
bordel j'ai le droit quoi bon ça bah
écoute ça va écoute ça va ce petit match
bah je suis pas confiant ah ouais ouais
t'as tes confions pas bon remontant avec
ce je connais pas trop de niveaux de
mourir elle a fait un bon championnat
d'europe
l'américaine manière forte voilà presque
le top-12 péter uj mais écoute après
j'espère mais tu vois j'ai peur qu'à
rica soit plus fort but ça les champions
du monde 2015 de beats de glisseuse par
internet alors attention c'est pas que
ça existe alors tu te rappelles palais
cet événement fit complètement génial où
les mecs se retrouver dans la même pièce
est jouée or di fassa ordi un peu de
thunes rappelle un truc comme ça ouais
bien truc là bas il se trouve que ça
rica qui a gagné voilà donc ça mais bon
ok donc le très à l'aise à la souris
tout ça là bas et j'ai envie de te dire
est championne du monde c'est là
l'unique championne du monde de beats
par internet officiel ouais bah on est
mal quoi bein ouai mais bon c'est quand
même une info que je lâche quoi d'entrée
tu as raté
sous pression à tabriz fournissent
bonjour salut renault rno 84,31 il est
là il ya fou 31 aussi qui est là on my
way 21 parler mais qui faisait ses
excuses par un quoi delacroix qui
cucuzza d'hermann groles trotteurs ya du
monde aujourd'hui je sais pas s'ils font
on sait pas de parler de férié un jour à
regarder et chaque point bah oui
complètement
non mais je pense 8 mai les échecs sur
sur twitch tu te mets roland sur la télé
tu es bien nous dit le son n'est pas
fort je peux augmenter le volume 1 c'est
pas un problème un peu on peut augmenter
le son assez on est entre gens bien ici
allez fais péter les watts alors j'ai
augmenté mes super super est très
heureux marathon moi je suis fait je
suis toujours en recherche de savoir si
le truc a vraiment commencé fabre moi je
sais que je ferai partie je veux boire
ce jeune dame en fait je vois pas je
vois je vois pas de l'arrivée officielle
il ya il n'y a que nous qui sommes en
live je comprends pas en fait ah non il
est russe aussi son live les portugais
en fait il ya tous les lives of le truc
officiels et les espagnols aussi alors
est ce que il ya les portugais les rues
c'est tout ça et on a tous rien compris
ayant un changement d'horaire de
dernière minute on sait attendre les
espagnols aussi sont en ligne ouais donc
en fait il manque que les que les
officiels quoi du génie qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent c'est du jamais vu mais elles
étaient les turcs aussi les turcs ils
sont encore en rediffusion quoi ils
n'ont non mais je prête le problème
c'est comme je sais pas les pseudo je
sais même pas comment les voir si ça
joue la main non plus en fait j'ai pas
les pseudos la davie c'est le premier
match où je sais pas les pseudos bon
mari c'est soit maryse ce vague souris
blanche comme ça rarement ces souris
blanches la rigueur se répète
aya gideon qui me propose de faire une
partie en trois minutes
ça n'a aucun rapport oui parce que c'est
pas trop le principe non si on joue
contre gideon 7 mai marie j'ai passé je
suis en train d'essayer quoi tu vas gsm
ce bague attend choix que le truc
officiel il démarre et toi le général
ouais je peux qu il ya un monsieur 135
verges les joueurs clé c'est le mieux
possible en france après c'est du pipi
de chat c'est minable x à l'huile à plus
de lots à ça ça qui est bien que le
speed class féminin sur de chasse comme
c'est que je ne fais que commenter des
joueurs qui ont moins de points que moi
en fait
bon eh toi aussi du couple à bas du cou
hal gill avant quoi vous êtes nuls vous
ne voyez rien reçu très heureux quoi et
du coup sur l'officiel heures si nous
raconte ben apparemment il passe une
page de pub heures
2 il me regardait très officiel la sarre
des très officielle comme pub qui passe
je n'ai reçu mon truc cool monde mbiwa
temps je quitte chaise comme je reviens
pas en attendant sait toujours pas qui
vous bat as a ricané à settat c'est non
non non ces arches à ces paris qu'à ma
vie mais je regardais search mais il est
là il étudie des envies de clikeco arche
à montchaude donc c'est très intéressant
quoi banon mais il ya dernier dollar
audit ski aso a souri joue le rôle de
garde-fou chine on oriente son bel et
bien on regarde ce soit en attendant
avec jean vite à 4
un pronostic c'est génial ils jouent
contre mario ton est ainsi qu'ils sont
partenaires c'est le wolf ou non
attendent ils allaient noir ouais c'est
non c'est optimiste je pense qu avec
optimus qu il y ait là quoi est-elle
cheynis look en fait il s'en fout
complètement ça l'intéresse c'est
extraordinaire elle a noté que oui mais
il a quoi il ya des projets smart que
c'est quoi ces dames aussi rose sound
cavalière et 6 et dams et 6 c b
simplement j'ai un absolu sur ma tête
mais l'autre après l'autre il y avait le
cavalier la frmb intérêts c'est très
intéressant que dieu lui dit gg pour un
commentaire
on voit ce que l'on s'est passé
ça l'est peut-être nous aussi on doit se
mettre à faire des pizzas quatre ans
même si les gens regardent pas parce
qu'ils n'aiment pas trop mais non
golfeurs de 804 avec vous deux pour dix
cantons avec la mort là on doit
peut-être faire les ddd stream beats à 4
y en a marre il ya aussi des pics à 4 à
2 j'ai quand même à la crise yahoo ce
n'est pas mal elle salue plus d'être
beaucoup plus intéressant mais trop
c'est un mec qui écrit saucisses ou
sociaux piquante
ouais tiens les revues qui hier soir
j'ai fait une grosse soirée
est ce que tu sais où j'ai déjeuné à
midi d'abord ce que j'ai dit aliénor me
réveillant je dis oui il faut que je
sois en forme pour ce soir il faut aller
manger très sain quoi donc du côté des
autres outils face aux asiatiques
ouais j'ai pris une soupe passionne je
fais aucune faute moi je je suis très
heureux
ah bah oui et gers est très connue quoi
c'est manger très sain d'aidé que fekter
un peu mal en fait c'est suite face aux
asiatiques tut tut tut tut faire
n'importe quoi sur la porte à tous les
problèmes
c'est très connu pour sa gouaille de
bladen donc forcément un conseil de
lumière ouais c'est un conseil vraiment
de de haut niveau quand même un conseil
que tu suis d'ailleurs un bain pour le
fait des petits sushi demain aussi
mais pour souffler quoi lui tout seul en
lice ou plutôt très bien réelles a dit
jeudi très bien à plus et y dit si tu as
des problèmes d'allergie par là l
assembleur mieux là au moins il ya aucun
risque face aux asiatiques étaient très
tranquille au niveau des allergies ça
c'est très important quoi ces chèques en
fait ils marchent sur la
sur la manière dont les autres pensent
je pense c'est pareil avant même qu'il
va dire que c'était c'était sympa de
faire ce soir on était à l'endroit ouais
ben bella lui fait sous pékinoise
souvent ce à quoi le truc un peu piquant
là ça s'est bien passé transpirait déjà
dit les toxines ouais c'est ça c'est
beau talent tessin que je vais te
défoncer parle avec rolls et où en fait
tu rajoutes du xive au coach tu sois une
le mal par le mal c'est connu quoi bah
oui mais bon goût de mentionner des
endroits je vais des endroits où josé
chaque appareil variés plein de clubs
mais sinon dans certains bars ajouts et
la peau pinacle des tournois de lundi
soir et de café de l'est le vendredi des
idées et pas décider des bonnes idées il
ya aussi jardin du luxembourg peut-être
au cas où si on joue en extérieur
comment chaque jour y allier les joueurs
qui viennent bleach et ou quoi bahia des
blitz heures il ya des habitués c'est
qu'à cannes ils ont essayé de faire un
peu la même chose
ils ont une étable ouais je pense qu'on
ira jouer j'ai ouvert la mer ou mai sur
la croisette ya des tables tu peux tu
peux jouer donc elle coule c'est pas mal
un passionné des jeux en extérieur
les gens aiment bien pour s'arrêter de
jouer ouais c'est cool c'est pas mal
quoi doper la tête de contenu ce déchet
qu'à un gymnase où quoi après simple
comme ça c'est après c'est un sport donc
ça peut être intérieur et que ça avait
presse suivant les conditions est ce que
tu es plus fort en inter en extérieur je
suis arrière si hâtif et christophe
tunis il ya du vent comme ouais mais ça
des gens indoor fin mai voyage beaucoup
feront mine d'or parce que tu es plus
dans la maîtrise donc très j'aimerais
pas que l'option s'envole non mais c'est
ça les éléments extérieurs peuvent me
gênait pas je comprends pas facile mais
ça c'est un peu aussi est ce qu il fait
lourd tu vois pas ce que vont enfin fois
suivant l'échiquier leurs vêtements il
peut être un peu un peu différent aussi
thaci la plus avancée a peu à peu glissé
et chuté en plastique
bois sur simple adhésives sajoo 1 ça
change beaucoup de choses tassart jeu de
précision et de toute façon
bah oui les deux jt de way et oui
important mais c est ce que tu es en
bonne condition physique ou pas tu vois
et ce que tu vas pouvoir rester assis
pendant quatre heures les jarretières
fois les encaisser les quatre heures
assis quand même ben le problème de dos
tout ça
fata plus d'une personne italie oui bon
ben je je craque un fatah qu'après 40
carats 44 eur 42 je fus tu as une dame
de plus mais tu suis les ans pris de
crampes quoi on n'arrive pas à finir le
match comme un fou ya ma tante 3 mais tu
ne peux plus être plus petit bloc après
si c'est ça tu vois alors outdoor s'il
ya de la pluie tu peux récupérer
tu dois faire une pause machin tu vas
chez cicc y ait tant de récupèrer squibb
le pour pouvoir venir ajournement s'il
vous plaît
l'adversité pour ça qu'il est parti à
journée bah oui les mecs avaient pas là
bas mais pas les conditions pour
maintenance bien des athlètes donc ouais
maintenant maintenant non manrique soit
une grosse caisse qu'ils arrivent à
encaisser il arrive encaisser des
parties bon après par rapport à l'effort
aussi fab
heureusement qu'ils allaient jours de
repos il tourne généralement tu joues
deux jours ou trois jours maximum et
après tu récupères baddou
je regardais le giro bon ne venons pas
il sera ici comme toute la journée à
tourner à fond sur la [ __ ] et quand je
veux te dire bah maintenant c'est plus
confortable
bal à la salle de merde de meilleure
qualité alors du coup est-ce qu'on est
ce qu'on trouve
est ce qu'on sait qu'ils jouent à falla
ce que je vois à l'écran bon ça joue pas
mais de façon pire je pourrais regarder
le pseudo change à réussir à le voir là
ça discute sur le truc officielle du
calendrier d'ailleurs qui est que nous
aussi on a du coup on a le calendrier là
en dessous
[Musique]
jeudi le vent le vent je viens tu vas
prochains matches demi finale le 20 25
et 27 donc ce sera une semaine neuf un
jeu répond denis finale finale au moins
son gym laisser pas mal ça t'a par
rapport à ce que ce qu'on avait l'an
dernier on speech est sous ça ça
continue et parfois placé que le clan
des jeans à c'est quelqu'un de très
féminin au arica wa marisa et on a les
caméras belle caméras elles sont
générales se sont bien cadré quoi irina
crush dernier match n'était pas du tout
cadré
ce n'est pas porté chance non pas du
tout à fait comme j'ai vu de mes 3 way
cas les premiers froids et ouais ben oui
oui c'était bien enfin pédagogie c'est
un mythe clic je pense j'ai juste une
passe et un clip sur sur plus tard m'a
cru qu'ils allaient très gentil
marie-andrée il a vu naître simultanées
ah oui enfin y'a pas de raison du choc
qui sortit forme la porter à essai à le
chat et le char d'aller mieux vaut deux
mêmes charges
tu gères le chat ouais c'est important
chacha d'entrée
c'est bon j'ai géré chaki chakra haut tu
connais l'expression chaque saut ouais
enfin non je comprends pas le jeu passe
et j'arrivais pas à faire d'expression
avec chat échaudé je sais pas quoi et du
coup j'ai simplifié mais je suis en fait
c'est beaucoup les indices georges
chakra au enfin jérôme normand
pourquoi tu t'en met à rajouter des
démos parasites mais c'est rapide on dit
chat échaudé craint l'eau froide
ouais non mais tu vois c'est ça chat
échaudé craint l'eau froide n'en fait le
truc c'est que tu peux enlever offrant
fin en soi sauf l'open chaude froide il
n'aime pas donc je voudrais donc en fait
je chakra offert c'est beaucoup plus
intelligent comme comme extra ratant je
crois que ç'a commencé mais a dû avoir
chopé les pseudos super à main c'est
trop petit non mais attends attends
c'est tellement ridicule comme situation
je n'arrive pas à voir
attention quand de m'approcher de
l'écran zoom zoom
ouais mais je peux pas où mais je peux
pas où l'attendront attendant le chat
dit moi les pseudo c'est énorme je
n'arrive pas à les voir attend attend
peut-être là je regardais j'essaie de
regarder la ville jumelle cdu cinq
minutes attentes à tanger le un gâteau
le génial contre élégance tricks ses
toiles génial non attends oui c'est ça
c'est bon c'est bon alors attends je
vais récupérer les toulonnais doit être
génial pas tortue géniale
france emond à la partie femmes et donc
élégant stricte voire franck eba c'est
parti un petit système tor on s'appelle
ce trail col collon regulus à l'inversé
c'est génial de dire ça c'est un système
du livre je ne crois guère d'autre est
ce que le riz gluant
pour affronter également voilà en plus
les blancs et donc oui mais c'est
vraiment ça c'est une heure c'est
vraiment du jour et grâce à une moins
bonne tête quand tu joues à quitter
enfin visuellement c'est ce fameux truc
on va déjà parlé quand tu as un truc
avec les blancs avec les noirs ou avec
les bras avec les blancs c'est la
perception est complètement différente
d'abscon talent et noir en fait est
tellement heureux juste égaliser que sa
carte s'avère excellente a quand même
envie d'avoir une petite pression un
petit truc est donc passé que très
visuel en fait lorsque charles et blanc
seront pas moins 9 et voilà qu'arrive
devenir un jour nous accueillent des 5
tu vas ce cavalier à 4 à plus fous et
enfin c'est pas terrible pour pour
élégance rixe par vont donner très haut
on est pour marie-mai mais bon je veux
dire par là qu'est f4 dégage mais
peut-être qu'il y avait quatre épreuves
trois d'ailleurs de me 3,1 et
fourbissent précise qu' 6 5 mais
improbable bombe à la tour prend et que
madame tranquille en eux cette dame cet
essai savanes ont bougé c'est sûr ça va
pas non mais ça va très bien pour le
moment
alors y'a pas des trucs avec b 5 pour
s'en prendre aux pions aux cinq noms n'y
a rien et puis en plus silver duffoug
ici ce qui va arriver f54 bombe stoner a
fait ses cadres est libéral a cassé
trois pour amener le cavalier
éventuellement rebondir vers paris cinq
essais par match joué ses 400 pêche
aussi fou mais si sûr et c5 et deuxième
truc tout faux b2bi rayonne
elle va y retrouve la vue y rayonne
du coup on fait quoi avec les normes
leur tour à des huit je ramène ma
dernière pièce en jeu non je m'en suis
plaint de coûts envisagées à montclair
la fusée si c'est pas bête évite le quai
6-3 et elle cloue le vrai coût cavaliers
sur quoi l'autre a sûrement fait retour
d un an
parmi les autres noms jérémy sala
[Musique]
et toi tu en as fait quoi toi et mille
autres sommes pas forcément je sais pas
c'est juste qu'au détour des allées on
ne sait pas laquelle cote à tour des
huit levin en face de l'autre qui a
listé trois qui a aidé 5 partie tendue
en pour le moment partie tendue et qui
dit vrai
bon après ce qu'elle en d5 sera pas non
plus ivre il est bien placé mais bon ça
ils deviennent un peu ce cavalier quand
même hein tu vois j'ai pas envie de le
voir arriver en d5 mais je vois pas
comme on l'en but mais j'aime pas quand
les cavaliers commence à tourner comme
ça autour
enfin il y en a marre des fourchettes
des trucs et si on fait juste et six
trous et des soldats médecins touch mais
sur casse blanche
bon je vais où je peux scary cajou
beaucoup plus vite ça ça m'inquiète un
peu plus mais en fait non pertinentes ne
peut n'être pas très bien autant non
après je sais pas quoi leur cible ici
c'est ma chambre est ce qu'elle peut
jouer eux dans le iv ne paraît pas ça me
paraît pas fou fab je sais pas peut-être
qu'il prend bekara qu'on en voit souvent
windom quand tu prends trois ans
ça doit être très mauvais en fait j'aime
pas trop je déteste mais bon c'est
partir des quais à tassette qui saute et
attendu que les lycéens communion caïds
et 5 sur 20 qui est pénible mais bon
j'essaye en plus et carlier des quatre
jours pour filer du matos non mais de
façon il fallait même pas obligé de
prendre dans mon époque je panique un
fab toi tu paniques pas tu paniques pas
mais j'ai un bon voilà on est on est pas
tous grands maîtres 1-1 et moi je vends
accueillant des cinq je ne veux pas le
tolérer enfin joueurs dégagent je suis
ça ne m'intéresse pas je joue pas aux
échecs pour que mon adversaire est un
cavalier ou cinq on met le mieux placé
les chiens c'est pas tout à fait une
pieuvre mais il est pas loin
laval il ya un croco je résiste un
crocodile
bah c'est pas mal c'est génial en fait
nous appelle nature on s'attend pour
cette rue gouraud crédit le premier jeu
passe peut-être crocodile dundee non il
ya un film comme ça alexis gros couteau
serait était très énervé lui aussi voilà
fait que quatre mais j'aime pas du tout
aux quatre battues auquel est de fous
d'yves comme ça et à l'efo ville non
c'est pas mal mais juste j'ai
l'impression que le scénario de la
partie
t shirt un peu mais en fait tu peux
jamais faire dame des six cas qui a valu
à 6 échecs mais bondam ces trois ans
quand on bloque bien accro 5
c'est vrai que dams et trois fous et 5
non non mais elle a peut-être mettre le
camaïeu 5 et ou non mais ça va en fait
tu as des fois je hais mais quel point
qu'ils ont vraiment un k way rally en
août 7
je sais pas c'était possible cinq ehpad
hommes ces trois drôles de dames c'est
trois ou cinq faux 5 et b2 qui sautait
enfin quoique pas efficace et peut-être
qualifié cette à la fin bon sans le
sésame 3 machin pour tout ça prend non
mais tu avais vraiment cas et c'est ça
je crois que ouais ouais je pense qu'il
avait un gars là où y'avait dame ces
trois dames elles ont raté jeu quasi
sûrement qu'on n'a pas leur dis donc on
sait pas mais hélas du coup mais
peut-être que trois pour les blancs qui
défoncerait cup sous la colonne des
contres de toi mais tu vois la sphère
tour des sept maris blackheath 32 tours
bref sa quête où russell non ok tant des
poursuites qui est des solutions simples
et en cinq points pour 17 jours 7 jours
17 attendait pour 17 gagne 1.24 et
ok vous j'ai 4e tour des quatre juste f5
non mais je me fasse des cadeaux parce
qu'ils pensaient que c'était pas une
menace mais tout ça oui oui d'encaisser
quatre sait jamais une menace à alger 4
c'était pas mal bon écoute même sf4
permanente du modèle je pense g5 ou quoi
j'ai cinq courts f8 ce que roy évident
ça peut aussi être une option sur réussi
à faire recette
tu te places ouais ok bon bloc la
majorité ce point de jouer du coûtera
peut-être du kg degrés le 4 1 jour elle
devra ramener son roi sûrement avec les
non c'est pas mal de réussir à faire
baisser ce qui est bessette qui est des
six fait mais bon c'est un peu long
wallon probant bras je pense tu veux
dire
les investissements voilà il peut y
avoir un piège non ferreux cinq jours et
j'aurais tenté de laisser faire roi des
deux pour un b3 et ben non ça marche
parfois parce que là
ça a fait un nul oui les prochains jours
et stop pour but de la partie disons ça
c'est normal au vu de la partie ouais
mais ouais c'est vrai que maria pagés
très vite ça peut être un prêt pour la
suite du match
dans ce cas une propos 2 nuls et le jeu
l'équipe première du la première du
match fab auxquelles bon tu reviens donc
à 0 0 pour le moment et ça tient non
mais c'est une belle partie je trouve on
a bien tenu
mancel a déjà au programme bah moi je
m'approchais pas de nouvelles parties là
pour le moment que deux études chez
laffont jean yves ferri peut être sonné
aussi
ouais je suis un peu étonné je suis même
très étonnés et donc elles sont près 24
80 sur autre chose comme ça joue par
alain je pense leur vélo non non c'est
les autres choses comme way le monde est
ok barils à 24,82 en branle à 24,79 114
je sais c'est plein ouest les bords
harry callahan a été 25,40 je crois
qu'elle a un peu baissé 24,92 presque
jamais à l'écran m beaucoup de mémoire à
tous les grands maîtres
c'est un peu une certaine constante
du coup la femme c'est quoi c'est une
tire cloué
ok l'a4 j'imagine mais je pense pas que
les blancs soient mieux cette prime 6
caillage 5 des coups comme ça venir peu
triste et toutes ses cadres déjà à se
positionner les planches ce jour et du
food et tu t'es changer les dames sa vie
très vite vu quoi d'étonnant décision
finale mais je ne fais que ça avec
l'énorme secousse n'a plus agréable à
jouer en fait parce que qu'est c3 mal
placé bizarrement n'a pas d'avenir
caillage 50 ont voulu bouger cette fois
je sais pas je ne sais pas juste bizarre
comme coup chez soirée par le plus cette
fois c'est pas changé clément parce que
d'habitude fait pas un peu du hc 5,3
cette fois ci c'est par exemple avec les
noirs ou du hip hop actuellement c'est
5,4 les fouilles jean tulard même well
as me dire à quel âge qui tourne en
boucle
j'aime bien voir venir en aide 4 après
il ya le pion à 7 est ce que tu veux
faire tour des quatre temps des quatre
jurés pas de le part les options à 7
alors trois des quatre judokas lieu 2
non mais attendez 4 elle est mal passé
mais je défends donc d'un v8 logique
ouais c'est sûr qu'il a pas de vision
globalement ces gars là bas c'est petit
plus pour les morts dont quand même
tabbou a même sauvé foot non d'obtenir
pas trop du ciment peut-être qu'il ya
quatre lycées 5 des trucs comme ça ça
devrait aller peut-être caillage 5f cas
du coup mais peut-être peut-être kadhafi
5 et 6 juin
mais si l'on pouvait faire à bab tour à
6 il lui donne la colonne le torrent qui
n'as rien tu donnes club et c'est génial
bon la fab et 5 mais du coup de feu des
trous les dames c'est 120 subissent très
bizarre mais si je suis pas compris en
fait les quatre panneaux rebecca très
bien où tour à cavalli ses cinq tours à
7 mais je préfère beckham
bon ben ok donc pas mal aussi
[Musique]
ouais bon après je sais pas si tu veux
tout faire et ses cinq tours à 7 qui
prend des 3c prends tu as une fois pas
mal placé mon tonton derrière et après
non mais becaert préférée ça je trouve
que ça a laissé moins de leur jeu que le
ceux qui en détiennent dominé way
majoritaire savez c'est moins
d'amplitude
j'ai envie de danser des mots qui valent
pas forcément dire grand chose mais bon
donc on va fermer 4 ouais nan là il faut
fermer quatre sessions pas bon je pense
que n'importe quoi mais quatre j'aime
bien mou dam de tous ces cas au québec a
dit la dame le doute est ce que je peux
faire foods de fous j'ai 4 way et de
ouvre tout parce que de faire ces trois
des fantômes j'aime pas trop qui a aidé
la bisque pour toujours apprécié des
découvertes et autres car nous sommes
tombés on perd mais non mais tour à 8 h
la colonne bon 6,5 bon menace égale
attention mon prise elle va reprendre du
non mais ça va aller en fait pour les
blancs nantes va s'échanger le meilleur
hockey et j'ai trois ou qu'on peut tout
est changé
jacky quesnel gironde et royal perd deux
pions v6 à la fin mais ça fait juste nul
n apprend détroit a prises des trois
prises des trois prises b si c'est drôle
quoi baver en challenge league pour fou
c'est mieux pour cavaliers avaient
compté que des pions sur des mails
après maman blitz et même le cavalier
peut-être dans cette position-là précise
qui pour faire la fourchette mais bon à
la safer nul c'est sûr ça ne peut pas
question alors sécondaire fin où je
comprenais qu'annonce instants pareils
5.3 +11 plus un vrai mais combien de
temps de chacune cadence 90 60 et 30
le champion ready pas très ambitieux
tout ça pourquoi pas après 1
aura t on vu que le match se débride un
moment et reste lâchers d'eau débutants
et peut-être d'autres assurer un peu oui
bien sûr tu te rassure tu rends dans le
match mais là avec les noirs elle lui a
un tout petit peu essayé je pense que
j'ai de tout ce que je voulais non tu
peux pas faire plus en plus qu'à la
faire c'est bien joué parce que t'as pas
le temps de faire tourner un fou ces
quatre tours d1 on va te faire la date
retour des questions des deux steve
ramon vie prénom mais assez marrant quoi
ça fait pas nulles direct presse
affaires vous ces quatre blocs n'est pas
de chance décrit nord c'est que tu
flashes 4 pour fixer du chef 5 un jour
espère au prize est probable qu'un pion
pacios et échangent les tours avec les
blancs j'aurais peut-être fait tourner
la mairie tour mais tu peux changer les
tourtes est sûre tu feras nous attend
mais là je vais dire est ce qu'on
pourrait pas presque même enfermé la
tour noire
on va pas y arriver tour de chèques pour
reprendre et de deux partiront de partir
des années 60 il va faire rêve de elle
va faire la création d'un petit nul 1
partout
bon pour l'instant pas de grandes
envolées la position un peu un peu
bizarre le p6 quand même fab étoiles
ouais ouais ouais ouais j'ai pas trop
aimé non plus mais bon on ne s'est pas
trop mal passé poil pour autant non mais
tu vois c'était pas schéma c'est une
partie a paru bizarre fois fille
souffrant g7 ça m'a un peu faim tu fais
pas normalement quand même enfin ça m'a
étonné quoi après tu as le droit mais
c'est un peu étonnant donc c'est
toujours pas reparti je crois
donc le chat qu'est ce que ça dit ouais
donc chargé il ya pas très ambitieux
related ça sent la null null null null
on n'est pas on n'est pas encore bien
rentré dans le match non plus parce que
fabre pour le mans les parties sont pas
y'a pas y'a pas y'a pas d'envolées quoi
on vibre pas trop mais bon au coût de ce
début de match les adversaires touche et
puis pourquoi ça ne joue pas enfin je
comprends pas en fait ça arrive juste ça
enchaîne ça enchaîne s'enchaînent et la
télé tu as j'ai l'impression qu'on est
dans un faux rythme
ouais t'as dit j'ai même regardé sur le
truc officielle est ce que j'ai ce que
eux ils jouent parfum que j'ai même peur
d'avoir un bug je comprends pas trop non
non ça joue pas c'est génial en fait
peut-être que ils disent qu'ils les
difficultés techniques du coup bon wife
sur partir et ils sont peu se trouve au
pied son parti regarder un beat the
narrow dit ce qui quand ils sont libres
je croyais en fait chuter mais bon les
joies pack qui allie difficulté peut y
avoir en fait ça sert que tu est
connecté tu viens de finir ta partie je
vois pas vraiment ça j'ai du mal à la
comprendre complètement cgt difficultés
techniques m'ont la pluie a commencé à
tomber par à puce sont ouverts jeu
va-t-il reprendre quoi faire on se pose
la question
une pareille c'est qu'une petite bruine
rester sur le terrain oui moi j'ai pas
envie quoi je veux retourner vers le
vestiaire on ne s'est pas dérobé la
victoire femme de wang contre verdasco
oui j'ai vu bien ma noter enfin je l'aï
bas il bat un top un top il est combien
verdasco encore il y 25 joueurs mais
c'est beau le français ouais
je n'ai pas trop connu encore assez
plaisir donc ouais mais bon voilà
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres petites gens de
venir chez les français jouent c'est pas
mais il ya goûté il ya un goûter qui va
jouer demain je crois pas d'être sur une
nouvelle génération de joueuses qui
serait que tsonga gasquet tout ça c'est
l'art dix ans maintenant la lépi du
cabba mais dont quoi les nouveaux avoir
un bar avant j'ai pas encore trop vu
deux matches à roland écoute je suis
vraiment étonné la de ce qui se passe
parce qu'en fait les caméras sont
allumés j'ai faim je comprends pas de
quelle problème fois je me dis est-ce
que c'est pas moi qui suis dans un monde
parallèle qui gangrène la cieux ça me
parait face ça me dépasse en fait c'est
tu as déjà ce qu'il veut dire tu vas
internet je suis connecté sur le site le
site marge suivant lequel tu as et c'est
quoi le blem technique en fait mary gala
des grands dieux non sommes partis en
prend un coup de pied vers benghazi
j'ai dû attaquer la partie
ces nouveaux trucs trois poisons ya là
des grands yeux et donc à raquettes
s'est marié l'an dernier c'est ça oui
mais tu pensais qu'il y avait un gros
mariage en inde c'est qu'il y avait un
coeur à prendre
je t'ai mis en chemise tu devrais
arrêter là quoi mais du coup pour rien
ils ont enlevé huit bars ont pu konaté
raconter ce match est donc
gaillac tu dis tellement dans ses
ouvertures bas c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une slave à l'envers c'est
simple c'est à 200% une slave à l'envers
c'est la même partie plus ou moins qu'on
a suivi mais je pense que c'est un peu
mieux pour un train de se goupiller pour
les blancs qui ont quand même réussi
fabas à m peut-être à mettre quelque
chose sur re5 ici et du coup enfermé le
fou ces huit way part peut-être un coup
comme cavalier e 5 fab qui mettrait un
cavalier e 5
comme son nom l'indiqué à nom de 4 500 e
4 bon en fait sûrement qu'est ce qu'elle
veut faire c'est le cinquième match
force de 5 pour les noirs et quasi
forcée ici presque ouais si les blancs
points 5 7 rue des loges ton père et
fils qui font trois et ça donne l'avant
passe-t-on des six est plein de choses
intéressantes mais voilà un point de
lens avec les pros bien placé pour
revenir sur f5 au dessin ouais mais est
ce que c'est c'est plus que symbolique
ou pas vrai ça fait un peu plus frais
ouais bon s'appeler d'entretien déjà
qu'ils étaient quatre d'ailleurs je me
dis qu'ils te des loges devrait créer
des casses à la fin mais j'ai pas trouvé
enfin trouvé qui a valu aux cinq plus
toi pour essayer de jouer sur le fou
s'est vite enfermé
tu vois plus à dunga kiosque ouais ouais
ouais il fait yattaya qui est il refait
yatenga chine deuxième fois comme un fou
accueil des cartes j'aime bien yatenga
qui en d4 vous faut aussi ce pourquoi
pas un tuk tuk tuk le garde sous le
coude va faire quoi tour c'est un tour d
un watt wash bien les coûteux bronze
pour la table mais bon sens dans une
pression très symétriques new la
structure pioncer symétrique est donc
toujours très symétriques c'est solide
nice et moi c'est moi le feu el fuego
est-ce qu'on peut tenter du hayon peut
pas faire cailler h4 kf5 c'est toi quand
je vois six à chaque fois avec
l'évangile
le deuxième barrage aller ça crie ça ce
qui m'intéresse pas mais que c'est bon
comment quelque chose d'intéressant
fêtes osées chez ba oui à calais en d4
et d5 a pu ainsi stu ne veut rien voir
de la neige
je ne tolère pas mais bien fait car
peut-être jouable ce qui avait provoqué
depuis kf5 et ef 5
d'où la tac tac tac tac tout et du coup
cavaliers h4 je me fais quoi tu veux tu
faire yatenga qui en d4
soit ça soit g6 ouais mais tu fais g6 et
pleutres ben ouais mais bon enfin fab je
le droit ouais non mais t'as le droit
mais c'est un peu plus 3ème fin à ces
chiens on va devoir s'analyser des
variants de deux voitures ont peu on
peut pas on peut pas analyser comme on
veut pas de cache 4 boom g6 direct ouais
c'est bien joué mais c'est pleutre le
nom de la pièce fou c'est avec en
anglais c'est une révolution
en fait chaque pays un peuple et ses
pièces comme il le semble et en france
ça on a fait le fou ce que le jeu plus
roi parce que c'était un truc avec des
cornes sur la tête ils ont fait ça pour
le chapeau des tous des bouffons alors
que les tendances avons un chapeau de
l'évêque et les russes cov avait là des
éléphants j'ai des chevaux j'ai des
éléphants fin ça paraît quand même
beaucoup de plus logique ça tu vas pas
faire la guerre avec des fous quoi elle
se trouve à jour
non mais tu imagines l'armée l'armée
ennemie est morte de rire allez suis
arrivé qu'ils ont droit aux [ __ ]
bouchez vous les oreilles la fnh écoute
pas c'est très dangereux lui ce qui est
ici non non mais peut-être que la plume
parce que tulipes et ouais enfin on voit
les vallées sur un champ de bataille tu
vas prendre une plus monsieur or ce qui
va t'arriver
tu vas finir en mode miss andré dans
game of thrones très intéressant j'ai
beaucoup de plumes n'est pas le bouc ou
de l'anguille est interprète interprète
plus grand chose si on interprète plus
rien quoi je coupe le son que ni tête
quoi
bon du coup cette position il ya en
échange le cadre femme qui a laissé 4
qui arrive
il ya des gars c't'un gars qui partout
ça danse attaque le pion aux cinq web
pour tout compliquer donc oui il ya eu 4
est à quai ou weeds au 5 mai au plaisir
tous leurs pairs à l'arbre on a pris
quatre femmes oui j'suis pas trop pas
trop inquiète pas pour moi une chanson
de johnny un oumar bah ouais je suis
toute la france ouais ça serait pas mal
comme harry je serai pas le remix omar
sy je ne suis pas très inquiet par ce
[Musique]
qu'est ce que je vais des relations pour
le foot je crois qu'en allemand ça se
dit le sprinter besoin chaque pays sont
les sprinters
il court vite elle sert que les mecs ils
ont ils omis russell bonne quoi usain
bolt
ils ont cru que c'était en crise et les
jo qui en fait n'en après pourquoi il
sprinte aurait puisqu'une tour je sais
pas aller il va de côté est vrai à bonal
maïs et plus de distance c'est vrai que
je fais à 8h en vain courte tournée de
ouais ouais
du coup je vais plus elle se dit que
c'est un sauteur y soit ou pas je ne
sais pas elle fit le respect des lois je
passe sur le fil un échec c'est ton
métier là où ferrand web alors allo
faire parce que c'est pas le sprinteur
le coureur il convient de quoi je cours
je comprends l appareil s'est récupéré
le pion aux 5
mais bon ya ces six sous pression ouais
mais tant mieux parce que si tu prends
ses citoyennes trompions hiver puisque
ce morceau que j'ai trois palmarès
j'ai quatre anglais la planète rouge et
qu'ils voient ça serait difficile même
si non mais là les mouille pas là une
bonne position mais je pense pas qu'elle
fasse france et 6 avec avaya h karaté
français si sûr non non c'est évident
c'est évident donc elle par bah on va
voir elle par attac et la case f5 enfin
elle veut plus voir
elle veut plus voir le pion à cisco afin
dégage mais marie cavalia 5 qui c'est
quoi l'idée de cavaliers à 5
c'est peut-être cavaliers b3 peut-être
et 4 c 5 après tout c'est pas des trois
on fout des trois ans voire la cfl te
passe un coup de fil à te dit je veux
jouer dans le iv est allé tomate et au
clavecin ou kf5 mais j'aime pas trop ce
coupé a5 dual km paraît un peu non on
peut boire
ouais et b3 qui est en passe d'être
réussi
je vais bientôt bouger latéralement fou
g4 même s'ils suivaient tous les cas
zones blanches à ton tour tu as gérald
hamo 4 900 ou pire se fait justice et
jetons fesci bon là je sais pas si c'est
si grave 2004 regardée à deux fois
guy cavalli b 3 poule trappe et il veut
faire g5 après deux tests vih et 5 mai
sans que tu as un bon équilibre quoi
alors que tu avais juste un turbo plus
sèche donc dans le monde tant mieux
sinon plus et passe pas non plus non
c'est pas l'amérique quoi bon me brosser
d'islande côté déjà à mi chemin bas est
à mi-chemin famille habite à des vols
pas chers après oui c'est vrai aidé à me
caresse même à prendre pour la qualité
j'ai ciblé pour les clubs elle se
transforme ainsi qu'en fait le chat est
super fort ok f5
je m'attends à ce qu'elle veut pas faire
dame c'est ouais et fou c4 et c4 faut
aussi sur les dames g6 après suite d'un
produit dont je suis l a pris bon
maintenant faut résister c'est sûrement
gagnant mais jesse sous ses cadres des
trucs ouais mais non nous verrons
ensuite dame g7 s'étaient pas perdre je
suis normalement enfin je vois pas trop
comment tu attaques en fait non yahiye
gadahn là qu il ya il tiempo fab el
tiempo le temps ben 30 secondes c'est
toi c'est un peu short joue foulée
quatre fous p 4 pourquoi pas un bon
c'est pas trop pourquoi mais peut-être
qu'elle est juste l'une avec le dev
voulait tous rentrés échanger plants des
deux peut-être un jour marca fait elle
va faire confiance à va faire h4 genre
est une astreinte jusqu'à le fait une
touche à rien canon mais peut-être tu
veux faire plus on prend qui on prend et
roy g2l de la nation après c'est comme
grid choc contre le ou la baroche huit
années le truc c'est que tu trouvera
quand même le roi quand je comprends pas
en fait là ce qui se passe j'ai brands
hatch mott benjamin que tu t'es
complètement ouvert là avec avec les
avec les noirs voilà l a rendue là
calloc'h du coup mais il ya quand même
la tacc bond juste mais y avait quatre
femmes
[Musique]
j'ai rien compris
gbh car j'aime pas du tout juste été
oubliée de tous ont l'air un truc comme
ça
après tours c4 par contre très bien joué
1 qui mettait tous pour l'action et là
un petit coup comme à 5 tours à 4 pour
faux pas ses pions dommageable c'est pas
mérité de perdre celle là au pire tu
converti pomme pourrait perdre c'est un
peu dur à les verts voient voir quoi là
je pensais qu'elle allait faire tourache
quatre tours par h5 pour gagner le pion
mais tout est vrai nom c'est sûr
améliore un machin a tourné six échecs
et frau f2 et le tout arrivera cet os
est temps de lui d'un jour et par à
jouer pour essayer d'embrouillés avez
vous tourné quatre bien joué ok bon jeu
au pied de pas après tu parles un
spécialiste des jeux seul club au monde
ouais mais il ya tous les fous qui ont
fait des pattes avant et puis voilà
enfin base des fêtes un peu plus alain
un peu mais je pense que le tempo d'un
problème à une française un très
intéressant qu'est d2 ouais les dessins
qui comprend la peau d'âne je pense
c'est ça ouais la partie parti un peu
partie précédente
ouais dominé mais un peu quand le même
scénario que la partie 1 j'ai
l'impression on a senti mari qui prenait
le dessus stratégiquement mémé arica qui
m'a l'air d'être assez affûté en attaque
tactique tu vois donc du jeu de jambes
con way elle m'a l'air d'être l m'a
l'air d'être assez habile
j'ai envie de dire comme beaucoup de
joueurs indiens il ya une certaine
agilité dans les positions dans les
positions tactiques et je retrouve bien
la fab ce style
un tirage envie de dire l'inculpation et
donc voilà fait bon plan plus qui est
cette justice c'est bien il est bien
investi simultanément
tu peux pousser ont fait défaut les
pions de saint christophe à le grand
classique tête envoie ta majorité de 3,8
et puis tu t'avances est-ce que pcf ou
bessette est une idée ici fab ce que tu
me tues tu obéis 6 juin c'est au centre
jusqu'à ce pas trop la tête
je vois c'est simplement en fait un
accueil cherche pas midi à quatorze
heures de voix sylvie truc non non mais
ouais ouais je vis des trucs normaux
et elle est vraiment vraiment pas mal
quand elle attaque le roi c'est vrai que
tu sens genre de kosteniuk en un peu
moins forte
peut-être je l ai fait un gros match
comme ça dans skins well as bien joué à
la berge et franchement elle a bien joué
et gunino et c a fait un gros match
voilà la gagner avec beaucoup de
facilité mais je pense que il n'ya pas
que crunch qui a mal joué tu sais ce que
je veux dire non mais je pense que nous
explique je voulais quelque chose
oui mais elle joue vite et le nom est la
différence avec les autres de ce que
j'ai vu enfin c'est ce qui m'a le plus
impressionné chez chez vanina sait que
vanina c'est la seule qui tendent des
pièges vraiment très sophistiqué quoi tu
vois enfin m même quand elle a une pièce
de moins et où tu sens que elle
s'accroche à fond le tarmac bas comme
tous les bons beats heures en fait et tu
sens que l a plus ça que les autres avec
kosteniuk peut-être aidé à certains de
ces pillages sophistiqués comme ça si ce
ticket que sa méthode actuellement
monsieur woerth préfet 4 kg 5 et sur
l'a6 tu prend aussi soin f saturées
comme kg 6
mais du coup comme toujours la colonne
qui a comme prévu des femmes chargées de
quoi après si tu reprends tu peux le
faire oui des plongées de m tu vas
gagner le super de ouais mais ouvert
ouais mais tu aura peut-être là le
prends aussi c'est à dire clairement
comment l'europe a tout réussi son coup
en attaque la dame g6 qui doit rester du
g22 le prix de l'eau ouais tu peux faire
la maj cet échec du coup les foules 4
mais ce pas si clair mais oui ça c'est
sûr qu'elle a calculé donc hériter 5
gyres end ce qui est pas mal
ok donc vous prend et la tête dame prend
pour éviter kf4 ouais pas raison il
n'est pas trop bougé il y avait le prime
soit 7 mai au kilo mandat prédateurs de
fou
et puis tu prépares tu 7 h 4 h 5 aussi
ce qui arrivait dans les pieds des
changes et le foot 15 manches 1 qu'elle
envoie le f5 ff5 5 f4 f5 5 ou f5 f4 la
rupture us et qui se profile est trop
inconstant donc 54 à fond et peut-être
g5 et peut-être f3 avec lebron joue à
fond je sais pas si c'est bon matin ce
qu'elle fait mais moins elle vise le roi
bâle vise la croix quoi elle a créé sur
instruments clarens tu sais aussi ce que
y'a pus réussissent et afu il y aura
foule 4 et 5,5 6,6 ou béthouart dameuse
this way voilà mesdames ça ok donc tu
dis eu cinq fauves et 3e dp6 damev cette
étude et fantou en rayons x
ouais bien joué à fab bien vu façon je
crois qu'il faut peut-être entre elle
aborde ce qu'on refuse ce moment-là
satya sai renfermé façon après d'autres
où pranger 6c d'autres options l'option
à choisir m
il faut prendre les six ici ouais la
ville vient sûrement mais bon oui de 60
tu peux pas prendre en géant j'ai vu
cela vous prend tiana canada touristes
qui arrivent et roche pas tellement plus
donc puis on prend et sur fouet 4 c'est
peut-être juste retour 5 ou 6 mai pour
cent que j'ai trois pions le frein vous
ces lettres
dams et quatre échecs mais bon on
échange tout un ouais c'est pas mal ton
truc
bref un c'est pas brillant brillant non
plus un mais ouais mais on sent qu'on
s'en sort donc faux cadres ce qui a
peut-être est-ce trop intermédiaires ou
qu'elle tout passe quand même être
interdit à la dame c4 et menacent un
retour de cette année je vais peut-être
faire dame c4 et puis on prend des
quatre ici ouais tu la gagnes un pion
mais finalement on va t'oublier toi et
tu vas tu oublies rentres tu vas rentrer
jeudi de chance peut-être mais je pense
que d'affaires se nomme c4 c'est logique
un ok mais je prendrais me paraissent
quand même logique non de prendre
l'avion ben ouais c'est ça c'est la
partie qui est peut-être fou prend un
cadre comme francis a peut-être pensé 74
et or ces deux comme ça mais on doit
tourner en plus
ouais mais je vais peut-être faire tout
un jouer sur dur f4 non mais sûrement
pas le dire avec sa patrie mais il ya
des chances et des chances ok c'est pas
mal comme on n'était plus trop fonctions
pour marié ok peut-être au-delà du coup
l'homme datant du 2 août ou retour à 20
et je te mets une tour en effet les
chiffres et tours 2 1
ouais ou une île comme des brutes pour
deux ans donc je l'espère tour ces deux
qui ont tous ou alors on fait des cinq
meilleurs du genre en nombre tout de
suite on attend mais bon c'est la même
chose des f3 bâfra j'ai gâché quatre
trios un référent h d'ouvragé trois
coups gagnants hulu 30 un coup mais là
c'est fini j'ai quatre oui voilà c'était
gagné l'égalisation les amis
bf3 c'était un peu space non comme coup
aussi bon alors du coup des 5 des 6
miles
allez c'est parti
mais justement je trouve que parfois sur
des coups comme ça elle prend un peu
trop de temps crois tu sais que tu vas
le faire des cinq canons way la d6 tu
sais que tu vas faire là tu pousses
l'hôtel fait quoi puisque sur tours 17
tours tour 16
on tourne autour de soi pour être cadre
tour et quatre tours russie soit tour c4
ouais bon ça plein de chose faite elle
renouvelle la menace en gros 17 et tours
s'est vite j'ai pas j'aurais peut-être
préféré tour f4 quand même mais bon
bonton fait quand même 17 bref cette
toile quatre échecs
oui c'est bien ça
roy machin tu prends f3 quand ils
prennent tournée cet automne cet échec à
la fin tu va taper g7 a va taper b2 mais
tu es pions sont tellement plus avancée
que ça va gagner à nouveau des noirs
c'est de ne pas prendre des allures
temps combiné mercantour trop d'échecs
on verra quand on y arrive fabriquer des
7 je suis moi et toi tu viennes attend à
4 seul coup là toute façon non je passe
deux comme c'est ce qu'on voulait faire
on recettes
aussi si tu veux ton coin francs il a
peut-être tourcoing en fait ça je
pensais cela fort trois noms autour de
trois arrêts 3 1 tu voulais rentrer en
f7 assez bon à prendre et ça tu que je
te fais chaque échange dînatoire ouais
tu gagnes la tour est né donc c'est un
problème
oui enfin tu aurais fallait faire trois
des six du coup oui mais du coup tour
des trois rois sur la colonne c'est
ouvrait chaque ancien tu peux empêcher
pas quoi acheter loigne bien ouais bien
comme il faut mais bien comme il faut on
croit
elle va faire quoi la faire voyager vite
ce qu'elle veut bong un juge le 8 mars
mais bon je suis pas sûr que ce soit six
gagnants que ça en fait là maintenant et
près de 4 à 5 du blocage en taser
c'est peut-être parce qu'en fait le pion
il est il bon de ne pas la totale va pas
jouer avec b5 non enfin je crois qu'un
ténor var et oui oui tu as raison mais
on comptera versailles si mal autant
après un public et une seconde de rage
ou en fait mais aucun problème sur le
produit fait plusieurs concessions de
mary domine mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est tariqa tu vois elle a ce truc des
joueurs qui sont plus forts en blitz cd
genre de roseaux quoi tu as du mal à les
battre
ben tu as et un fou tu es sur terre
battue ça la terre est lourd défi elle
renvoie les balais qui en fait tu
t'énerves et tu n'arrives pas à finir
est en tout cas les cas la chose est
devenue ouverture bizarre elle joue avec
les nerfs avec thé blanc ou delphine
hollandaise adversaire intéressant pour
une ariane attaques indignes du disque à
arica celle à simona halep des échecs
elle court de partout et robin les
balles bon allez faire quoi c'est
hollandaise moi j'arrive pas à les jouer
avec les noirs et donc avec les blancs
non plus je comprends jamais rien ce qui
se passe c'est une horreur bon ok ce
soir sont une sorte de françaises
fermeraient beaucoup de cases blanches
bonne chose les blondes que faire un
truc comme fou et 3 to et 2 g 4 x 4 n va
le faire faute roy fra fdj 4 400 g
théâtre est bon ou trois parfois jusqu'à
très content et fier de faire g5 1 pour
essayer avec la troupe
je prendrai pas chaud f2 et si je peux
faire c'est quatre trésors écrits parce
que t'en fous de cases blanches il va
rayonner francis âprement mais ça peut
peut-être tout gagné actions mais je
suis pas convaincu toi parce que tu
gardes la colonne des ponts d'être aux
arriérés la caisse des cinq portes
j'ai l'impression que tu te fais dans le
caca tout seul parce que tu as beaucoup
poussent à la droite ouvre la position
le à mon avis le contre eux je peux être
peut être assassin c'est dingue avec les
noirs ouais
et puis tu gères tu as dame tutoieront
décès qui est multi ce qu'il est un des
trucs comme ça mais bon faut voir ça
dure que les blancs ou mais peu km 4
mais aussi des quatre ans qu'elle veut
faire un coup peut-être malin comme
cavalier ah non ça marche je voulais
faire cavalier f6 tu vois mais a poussé
505 ouais mais c'est l'idée de ramener
le cavalier rapidement en d5 et de bon
écoute 4 truc c'est que s'il est bon a
affirmé le couvert sept mètres un truc
ronde à 6 même si on verra si je te fais
d'amd 5
ouais bah tant pis on met peut-être de
le faire parce que si tu es fou prend
effet de couple en effet je la sens bien
en fait ouais mesdames agathe non madame
e411 était chiant ok alors j'aurais
peut-être dû faire dame prend des trois
lieux de jeu là c'est la qualité sais
pas si ça mon roi ticket que les jeunes
ont d'après ce que tu fais un truc comme
h4h de toute façon tu défends pas juste
bien ouais mais je crois que le h4 et
non je veux pas me laisser mettre en
boîte la ce qui efface qui est en train
d'arriver c'est un peu le scénario que
j'avais envie d'éviter à la fois leur
dit pas si les blancs on peut mettre le
client week end des 6 ouais c'est ça je
vous même le moins indécise d'ailleurs
qui peut on pas maintenant que leurs
fruits nous on est prêt si si si si
l'important pour 2,8 pourquoi pas un
tour de vis est logique mais trois on
imagine ou x 3 1 3 3 x 3 x fuite
ab3 à spa met ça moi j'ai envie de
sacrifier la fnp
mais comment mais je ne sais pas comment
peut-être ces cinq de prendre il faut
ensuite on donne au sein du bon là et ça
peut aller quand même
mesdames à cinq je sais pas ça m'a parce
que quoi qu'ils aient bechis
sociologique de prendre vous décisif où
des six fait toujours mouche et ken et 2
qui valait bien soutenir c'est ce
qu'elle va faire
la tour en lamé ou est ce que je peux à
faire tourner des huit pour essayer de
comprendre ce qu'ils apprennent bon
paquet de qui va arriver très vite
bâle novartis et trompe un deuxième
temps ouais il peut mettre la dame
peut-être en truc c'est que ça en fait
on réussit plus à revenir en jeu quoi
c'est horrible non ça se passe pas bien
attention babrak dam des trois auxquels
meilhat veut pas y avoir juste tour
c'est un tour d un et genre en fait tu
repères encore des tempo sur la dame là
là ça sent pas bon c'est sûr mais bon je
sais pas peut-être que je vais arriver à
faire tourner avec du bois fonds à
l'epic et le cadre mais bon mesdames est
la douane tarif 3,5
il ya dame g2 qui peut afc 5 c'est bien
joué ça muehlhaeuser aux objets quatre
longueurs de oui mais bon il ya un peu
trop de trucs dans tous les sens elle
reprend de seine en deux départs dont je
pense qu'elle est 5e juste ont pu
prendre les cavaliers aux cartes mais
bon c'est juste un compte plus sage
ouais ce qu'il fallait tenter de ramener
sain ce n'est que ça marchait presque
d'un prend des trois genres en pratique
pourquoi en tout cas fallait peut-être
tenter quelque chose de plus depuis
l'agressif tout en sachant que c'était
pas bon objectivement mais tu demandais
à l'adversaire de vraiment bon après
avoir pourtant perdu conduisent pas
l'amérique du stylisme c'est déjà un
problème
bon elle réussit à rentrer un peu alors
réussi à se donner quand même quelques
chances pratique là c'est bien des six
qui ont passé arrive à les marcheurs
blanc par omar qui marcheurs blanc ils
ont fait ils ont fait pschitt un ouais
ouais sainté menaçant bon dans cette
partie ouais mais au final palmarès des
marcheurs blanc 3 4 noir ou très bien
pour bien mais ok ça va déjà répression
du tout c'est pas mal finalement
on était défaitiste moi le premier bob
sa démarche en blanc passe donc du temps
si je les ignore
nous avons fait chier pendant vingt
coups à fait clair et et marcheurs blanc
l'option 2 - oui bon bah qui est trop 4
3 4 enfin tout ça va pas durer très
longtemps
attendez on va le deuxième marcheurs
blanc fin le roi de la nuit là à mon
avis il va tomber que je t'amène verser
5 millions d'animaux ouais bon alors est
ce qu'il ya un truc genre dames 7 et
tout comme v6 nous et je vais faire
tournoyer sur d'année si je vais faire
tour à deux mois mais peut-être votre
tour maintenant je voulais essayer
d'aller mater enfin le pote comportant
ce congrès c'est jamais même mal et où
reims et pénible en bon prod'homme
tristement g7 mais le fais tu avoues non
mais quand à cantat le pion à f4 cette
donne quand même super envie si tu
doutes sur la deuxième s'est tout de
suite matin bah ouais bon pour l'instant
tout est contrôlé mais attention le
droit je pense que faire je pense est
forcément tour
la mesure tu fais la galère avec les
blancs pourront jouer je pense à 2007
on peut aussi faire dame des sept aussi
méras damache tarn et d'amateurs à
tourbes et de au pire aurait dû coûter
am-dam g7 j'aime bien moche que ces
lieux là que j'ai cette dame français si
saddam des quatre mois c'est un peu de
chances pascal maimon d'alzon dans les
cas d'anémié by way savent encore bel ne
menace pas grand-chose damage 3 ménage
pas toi j'aime pas la marche pas parce
que tu donnes tout refait tu crées tu
crées une menace mais qui va dans la
fonctionnement ouais bon tremplin pour
ça as pas très bien joué et la
maternelle va faire de mieux
tam ou t3 ça va quand même ça a quand
même tenu à prouver cette décade père
échec
bon c'est pas mal de papiers je
suspendrai les vandales pendant un long
moment la partie elle est ce que tu peux
même essayer de la gagner non pas dans
leur trop faible
aujourd'hui chaque nom me dire tu pue ça
mais c'est donc à 30 secondes l'autre à
2 minutes aussi et ça c'est une
constante dans ce match et c'est un
problème le temps ouais on a
l'impression que on a l'impression que
marie est un poil moins forte mais aussi
le match pourrait tourner tout ce que je
veux dire c'est pas non mais ça va quand
contenu juste un peu plus longtemps
non mais tu te dis aussi peut-être c'est
physiquement enfin qui ont rigolé tout à
l'heure en début de match mais en fait
le physique ça quand même une
voilà la résistance et il ya des matches
où je sais plus que c'était calme match
de ce pitch est féminin ou quand même
pas senti que après 2h30 de jeu
ces atomes ce qui est justement qui
était un peu bas en fait c'est elle qui
était sous pression là pour l'appel mais
tu sentais qu'elle résiste à un moment
donné elle a lâché en fait mais
mais tu vois tes pas à l'abri d'avoir un
coup de mou en 3 + 1 ou 1 + 1 et
peut-être que vu que le niveau est quand
même moins fort qu'en speech as
masculins tu vois des nacaso par exemple
ok tu sais que ça n'a pas complètement
lâché normalement parce que parce qu'ils
sont 2008 et que et que voilà mais là
quand même niveau 2005 feed c'est quand
même un peu moins fort ça peux tu vas
craqué et tout d'un coup lorsque
toujours non mais enfin je sais plus si
c'est même quasiment janov qui était il
est temps d'abandonner papa oui oui et
oui les sessions d'entraînement ça
durera deux heures des heures des heures
après 8 heures juste en fait ils
comprenaient pas ce qu'un an dit
continuer à être bien et qui n'est
jamais une pièce on d'un coup analyse il
en fallait plus pour sa part des pièces
sont prises
c'était juste ok de la pause quoi et
l'autre au québec a remis jeudi leur
défaite d'affilée est mort à distance
c'est quand même quelque chose on est
donc à nantes passé nu ouais c'est du
niveau des gens dont tu parlais de notre
la source ouais c'est ça que tu sais que
ça va durer ça va jamais ça va jamais
baissé pavillon koala bon cette fois çi
de nous à cette peinture étonné par ce
choix justice femmes je ne comprends pas
en fait ce coup hop je comprends pas du
tout parce qu'en fait on te dis quand
même toujours que c'est la pièce que tu
veux échanger avec les noirs l'objectif
c'est la justice je sens quand même une
phrase fragilité côté marie sur cette
pierre qui n'est pas très impressionnant
pour ses 400 way dans les x h x ou jet
set c'est c'est étonnant enfin juste
tellement fait engueuler par mur tu as
pour avoir fait ça dans une partie une
fois je suis je me suis fait traiter de
tous les noms qua non mais enfin tu vois
c'est grave très grave ce que tu joue
aux échecs quoi faire c'est une question
que 5 des morts concorde
ouais
en fait non mais d'un autre côté c'est
juste ça m'a pas l'air si grave en fait
de faire fois je vous prends g7 c'est
juste que je sais pas à vaincre
je m'étais tellement fait engueuler pour
a fait ce truc là c'est à traumatiser là
ça m'a traumatisé vrai oui qui ne
comprend vraiment rien non mais le truc
c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire et
clément près mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
les noirs bah je vais doubler tour non
mais en gros je sais pas combien on doit
essayer de montrer quelque chose contre
la pire c'est pas juste un truc tu
égaliser en fait c'est vrai que ça il
faut 3 tu pourrais jouer ta meuf de fou
quelque part enfin oui toi tu en as
besoin de ton faut trois genres al taïs
r quand même non mais là potentiellement
plus j'aime pas parce qu'il est noir le
plante ça peut être avant de faire un
jeu 5 h 4 tu fixes tous les trucs que
sur 15 mois un choix du coach 5e 4 et
s'appelle chiant les gentilhommes oued
mais je suis d'accord avec toi c'est
pour ça que j'ai du mal à comprendre
vraiment l'idée derrière ce fou ce fois
je vais en avoir une un mariage ou bien
au passé trois mois et cavaye âge c'est
un peu c'est un parce qu'on va rire n'y
a pas de menace et non cotées blanc là
pour le moment nombreux tu veux ouais
ouais non ça fait h 5e carrément pas mal
ou à un bon elle je pense qu'à le faire
cavalier 3 et sans prendre option pour
tous et robin dans le fait direct fait
c'est ça le truc les gens sur nes ici si
étonnée par par un échange de coups de
15 heures c'est que tous les pions là
sont sûres sont sur noir en fait pour
les noirs et donc dans ce sens là ça
paraît plus logique de mettre bas de
garder le foot cases noires avec les
blancs parce que c'est un fou qui
pourrait permettre d'attaquer ses pions
justement et de colmater les wallabies
genre à toi la casse des deux
bien phu qui tiennent la caisse des jeux
mais clio 3 lat fait que 3,30 hors dette
et doivent plus trop de clients déjà et
vraiment le caillage 5e 4 c'est un
problème mais je vais sont très mal
partis
un autre problème c'est d'amener 600 m
pour juste s'octroyer la colonne de l'as
arrivent de partout et ça a convergent
de folie autour des 3 ok mais pour faire
gaffe aux vous promettra ces deux mamans
voilà les cavaliers h5 aussi parce que
ça m'a vachement c'est juste le prochain
coup droit long ça c'est un truc qu'on a
envie de faire depuis milan le voir je
le crois même pas mesdames c8 peut-être
sur la save
c'est chaud non c'est pas très pour les
bombes sur wes et chant classique vous
prend des droits voilà tu vas reprendre
du fou mais bon elle résiste bien
bîmes ça marche ça qu'est ce que c'est
que ça puis on prend là tu en prends des
points mais dans l'est vaudois qui est
des frontignes xiii j'ai pu aller dans
ce sens non même si elle est habile en
tactique 1 quand même vite la petite
arricau petite facile titre que salaire
mais elle est habile un bal à la salle
parce que plus on prend mieux 3 pour
prendre des trois donc là avec leenhardt
a plus que toi tu te retrouves sa vie
même pas d'ag être même trois quatre et
puis j'ai voiture bouché ouais tu peux
prendre à 4 tu peux prendre à 4 est
envoyé à reprendre la tête
on n'est pas le prendre
féd 1 me cinq échecs je sentais qu'elle
vaut essayer de placer un fou prend ces
deux tu vois mejia dame prend non me l'a
juste le faire du fou c6 est accablé
trois matches on ne marche vraiment plus
fort que marcheur lancions beaucoup plus
dangereux vrai coup d'essai de fouille
bien non mais une bonne partie des
vainqueurs
non mais ça fait un peu peur la
fragilité quand même fable dans la dans
la pire que côté marie parce que c'est
pas franchement c'est une vraie
fragilité stratégie que j'ai
l'impression dans cette position et
montrer ce fait deux parties qui a reçu
l'équipe fail0verflow blanc ouais non
mes skis oui et puis ce qui fait peur
c'est que s'est pas départi spa les
parties où tu te dis ça c'est pas passé
à grand chose quoi j'ai l'impression en
fait que c'est la conception total de la
pierre que qui est oif toutes les autres
lignes
ouais il faut que le ca t4 vos trois
dames des deux fois ci c'est bien mais
pas quand je vais le petit rajout de
grandes capes 3 et 4 oui oui bah oui tu
fais une attaque un jour d' attaque
anglaise
mais si cette position là va pas un pays
un problème aujourd'hui vaut mieux
changer assez vite quoi que de perdre le
match jusque là dessus ouais après un
que tu pourrais faire c'est le jouet le
truc tout est changé d'âme dit quoi tu
mets le x e 2 tu prends 1 5t change les
dames
non mais bon pas à lire la pire que
cette chance et chez le 3 t'as le droit
de l'agresser bon alors une nouvelle
petite hollandaise fab acteurs ont versé
color colle au colorado reste une versa
pas ce qui est un mauvais choix de jeu
de t4 aurait peut-être tenté la pire
quatre couleurs inversées
bon alors double filles enquêteurs ont
vu pas mal mais je n'arriverai jamais à
comprendre l'harmonie des pièces je te
jure femmes c'est un truc parce que je
comprendrai jamais ah oui je pense
qu'elle va faire au quatrain moment
qu'ils sont pas sans voix la voix et
mélanie jeu comme ça mais fait même la
position qu'ils résultent fait je vois
pas en quoi c'est cool je comprends les
gens qui ont des 3 et puant d'un peu
mais je comprends pas le palmarès de ce
que tu as voulu faire en fait
je comprends pas cette ouverture
s'arrête je sais qu'ils jouent comme ça
je vois cette position je vois la gueule
du trio qu'ederson mais oui mais en fait
mais c'est un truc qui jouaient enfin tu
avais le mec quand malagnou couche peu
comment il s'appelle oui bon ben ok mais
tu joues ça tout à l'heure je comprends
juste pas enfin y'a des fois je vous
chie c'est un mec je pense que si on
parle de n'importe quoi en fait on ne
pourra jamais d'accord c'est revoit le
monde de manière complètement différente
ouais étriqué qui j'ai fait pareil mais
je tenais pas que ces moments en fait
c'est ça le truc c'est que je comprends
que c'est jouable au chalet discute avec
vannes mais louise peut être une arme
intéressante sur gueye jouer pour la
gagne avec les noirs ou quoi la
hollandaise il se peut être intéressant
mais c'est une position compliquée
machin est tous donc il m'a dit que
c'était pas si vos faces paraît en mots
et en fait mais juste je sais pas
vraiment je crois qu'on n'en veut dire
je suis pas plus con qu'un autre moi
j'ai envie d'y croire à la hollandaise
non mais ça suffit j'ai regardé partie
de malagnou que je me suis fait une
culture mais non mais dans la tombe
ça a pas convaincu non mais non mais tu
assez spécial comme ouverture et du coup
je me dis est ce que les mecs si tu leur
parles de n'importe quel sujet en fait
de toute façon tu tu comprendras j'ai
enfin tu seras jamais d'accord j'aurais
tendance à remobiliser sa base est
apparue tour à tour de vis tu comprends
pas non plus tu vas enfin je me dis
pourquoi pas tour dès ce soir 17 ford et
je comprends à cette position fait la
touche pas sa victoire 17 doublettes ont
sonné à priori logique mais mon tour une
pourquoi pas plus tard qu elle me faire
de 5,1 rebonds les gens ce calvaire
saint claude pour 1 470 ch
je me suis dit ok au 5 juin 2005 et
utilise la case de 3,5 d'abord ok
pourquoi pas on a dû dame prend
peut-être ensuite pas tout de suite
parce qu'à ses saints qui s'est plus
tard peut-être même du p4 pour
s'octroyer à la casse des 4 mais bon
j'avais livres 3 mai trouvé ça que je
suis juste pas si on voulait ça
peut-être mais tu vas voir que
c'est ce qui m'arrive toujours c'est
qu'en fait tu ne comprends pas comment
mais tout d'un coup les blancs ne vont
pas être moins bien non mais j'ai eu ce
scénario plein de fois j'ai perdu plein
de partie au jard son club est
complètement nulle en face que je suis
beaucoup mieux qui ne comprend rien à
rien et tout cas en fait il est mieux 4
à 6 ans ouais mais ça y est c'est non
mais maintenant il va peut-être faire
ces quatre ans tandis que les eagles
hayat nbc katanga car je ne l'avais pas
je n'avais pas celui-là bon mais ça a
toujours quand même pas au bac pro
catastrophique
le respect c'est juste qu'on attend on a
ledge grecs ont eu 20 ans nathan admira
ennemi raqu o lo quoi bon ménage 5
pourquoi pas on louera les quelques
passants ont fait h4 rome h un tour je
vais vite ça suffit quoi on en voit sur
le roi non mais tout à fait à fab
c'est une position qui m'a l'air quand
même vraiment vraiment vraiment bonne
pour les noirs voilà prix fast 5 1 c'est
à peu près le du même acabit 1
ouais bon peut-être d'alger 2 pour le
mans parce qu'en fait c'est leur droit
acquis que le nôtre ouais
oui comme ça en plus il va venir
colmater des trois tu ne chantes est
d'abord décédé
ouais tu fais d'une pierre deux coups et
deuxième truc qu'on est clair avant
assises des voitures db4 autour des 5
fait ces casques en fait comme un agent
à 6 à la fin je suis ton père s'appelle
racisme et ouais enfin bon ça va pour
les pour les noirs encore complètement
ça va ça va mais mon bon jeu
henri guaino clairement oui c'est une
position qu'on comprend pas bon ma c4
dont vous prend nancy peut prendre
qu'elle va faire preuve à faire vous
prend mais j'avais bien bloqué aussi
enfin dam des sisters et 6 tout
maîtriser est appelée à 6 quai mais là
est ce qu'on peut faire jean retour des
je vais essayer cloyes je vois tu vois
alors est ce lié cette finale je pensais
pas qu'elle rentrerait dans cette finale
je pensais que ce serait tabou
non merci 6 2 le g13 étonnant des quatre
où je rajoute elle a craqué elle a cru
que ian callum c'était bizarre ne pas
faire tour c'est de nantes
je prends ça et chaque échec ouais ok et
oui c'est bien jacques échec trouvé deux
dalons plus tu montes tu auras moyenne
taille a pu isoler en plus donc oui
c'est ce et c'est parti c'est parti un
peu on recettes aussi possible fable ce
que vous froide et quatre n'ont pas fait
mouche 2 s'ils tombaient cinq tours à sa
deux tueries gagné 1,6 bon pis si on
bouffe avait cinq voix je te ramène ta
tour après en baie de hawke et vous
dites ok mais elle est bien autant à
lille ça me paraît ça paraît plus que
gagne à voile a fait tomber quatre est
pas idiot elle coupe le roi oui très
bien mais elle veut peut-être tour à 4 à
tout moment c'est vraiment toi
on verra déjà en position d'abus y aura
bien deux ministères c'est impulsive
technique ou mais le petit prince héros
à ces trois parce qu'en fait tour bien
droit à ces deux tours becquart 3 6 3 du
coup c'est peut-être un peu chiant mais
un gouffre au bk trois des six reprend
1,5 à 3,5
on va tomber si c'est manger devant qu'à
mettre le rang à cinq avaient fait rage
et 3g 4 mais je pense qu'elle doit
manger des cinq provinces il met la tour
des radios britanniques
oui c'est le plus logique 1 avant la
finale de pionsat ce regard on regarde
toujours les finales d'options fable ah
oui mais je reconnais vois la tour b vie
tu penses calme pour d'autres ils
tendent à tourbes et si ce que tu refais
retour à cinq bons retours sont bien là
on l'est toujours et je suis moins sûr
qu'on va gagner en weppes à ce que ces
finales à elles sont jamais simples h3
ouais t'as un truc c'est que l'option à
7 elle peut toujours le choper avec
tours b737 ou trois entrants j'aime bien
j'ai 4 h cadres dont j'ai deux tours
angers 201 peut être tonnant puisque
vraiment l'hôtel aurait de la tour en a
trois le vent venir et alba et idées
rocha 3f 3 non je crois qu'elle a les
cheveux à elle allait s'échapper ou g 4
mai g4 tu pouvais pas faire h4 bagdad
pour sagem pas peut-être mon mais
peut-être ça très bien spécial web
youtube façade où j'ai quatre autres
autrui c'est nul ça ouais vous facettes
et war 3 c'est nul facile webb 500 jours
et chaque mois elle a laissé échapper
mais alors où est ce qu'elle a laissé
échapper quel est ton g2 peut-être aller
bouffer les documents quand il répondait
50 prises multiples occasions
ouais non il ya eu des occases et des
occases et malheureusement ça va solder
par une nulle et une nouvelle fois tu
vois ces petites occasions ratées on
reste à -2 c'est un match serré il ya
peu de victoires s'est tu vois c'est pas
un moins 2 dans un match tu vas un peu
un great choc duda ou en fait ils ont
dit que froisser les 22 premières
parties sonia pas eu deux nuls coiffer
il a fallu attendre du pull à peut-être
moi est la vingt deuxième partie du
match pour la première nul mais le truc
fait disons il appela réussite avec elle
consent à ce qu'ont été les mieux en
fait elle a trop attention pas faire
avec cinq voitures et tout reste sept
matches et qu'on allait moins bien je te
perds ouais mais alors est ce qu'elles
étaient pas moins mieux vrai nom elle
était pas moins mieux elle était
vraiment mieux mais juste j'ai
l'impression que dans les pires que
quand même l'élève est parti là où elle
a eu des blancs elle a été dominée
j'ai l'impression que c'était quand même
assez facile à à convertir pour harry
car tu as alua pa demande un grand
effort tactique ou quoi pour pour finir
le job
non mais la simple que de
abd donc l'aspect durera longtemps mais
normalement je pense qu'elle serait
venue d'auch tard mais il ya juste pas
de progrès à faire un câlin on n'échange
pas toujours à 7,28 que car si tu sais
de fer philidor c'est pas très dur je
pense qu'elle seule soit son mari va
venir parfaire g5 1 jour et vérifier
quoi vous ne vérifiez pas c'est une
infime pas bah maintenant on a deux je
trompe cours près de trappes est allé
gagner une partie a pas si longtemps je
voyais un an et demi d aller vérifier
pour moi j'ai simplement quelques coups
de cul nul non mais là tu es obligé de
faire quand même un moment donné t'as
pas le choix et bordel j'ai le droit de
faire marcher le chaulage franck le
cloud direct ça vous savez j'ai cinq
essais hivernaux
bon j'adore toujours là jusqu'à fille
dont on a l'impression qu'elle sait le
faire - 8
elle sait faire elle connaît mais c'est
génial varie elle tente hyper longtemps
j'adore ça c'est pas genre je tente une
fois fini d'or c'est je te le temps tu
dis fois qu'on ne sait pas tuer que 2500
tu n'es que grands maîtres espagnols
étaient aussi partis avant j'aime bien
en fait cet esprit coubertin plus bon
l'important c'est de jouer nulle
ok bien dommage dommage toujours un mot
de oued dommage dommage parce que parce
qu'on a l'impression que ce -2 c'est ce
que tu dis fab jeu résultats penser
c'est que c'est sur des occasions ratées
quoi arica eu de bonnes positions à les
a convertis falandry 3 elle en a
converti deux de mémoire mais marie on a
eu de l en a converti 0 alors tu peux
être no name et d'autre qu'un point
serait mieux le match et puis il va pas
vous marquez des points avant la bagarre
devant une patinoire gagné une partie
des blocs est sûre ça aurait été le
conseil de mur face ils étaient si
l'état est calme et j'aurais dit ce à
quoi gagner une partie jouée un coup
après pas si tu gagnes vraiment pas en
mon nom et au 18 juin coup c'est génial
ça va jouer un coup c'est extraordinaire
comme conseil
oui qu'est ce que je dois faire je
voulais un coup ouais c'est ça en fait
il te dit tu prends les tournois une
victoire après l'autre mais après ça va
vraiment pas tu dois prendre un coup
après l'autre
mais il reste il reste à peu près deux
heures de match fabre encore des cinq
minutes je sais pas non c'est pas la fin
des 5 minutes je sais pas pourquoi ça le
vin c'est le conte technique et j'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre ce que c'est
une technique je crois pas je ne
comprends vraiment pas passer ça me
dépasse en fait là je sais pas faire je
crois parce que ça peut être comme
problèmes techniques fâche g20 j'ai pas
les mots tu vois non c'est qu'on n'est
pas technicien mais juste ces fermetures
jusqu'à enfin je sais pas c'est ça me
paraît ouais mais bon si la couleur et
bien grise c'est pas grave ouais ça
c'est le bon gris ça va
non mais ça va je sais pas quoi dire en
fait c'est c'est la première fois que ça
arrive et pas c'est pas un problème de
connexion c'est voilà on a une des deux
qui sait pas où cliquer pour faire au
match va je sais pas en face mais ça me
paraît impossible mais c'est pas
automatique
non c'est pas automatique c'est pas
bon j'avoue que j'ai quatre points west
bank en l'air un moment non mais c'est
particulier quand même fab
non je ne sais pas en tout cas pas les
mouches qua non on ne sait pas trop ce
qui se passe et du coup alors attendre
la 20 15 vainqueur de ce match
je vous condamne élan faudrait que je
retrouve le tableau mais je crois bien s
écoute bingo je crois bien que c'est le
côté daniel ans j'ai sous les yeux et
côté droit c'est kosteniuk que oui mais
bon ça rajoute chirurgie et c'est une
pire que qui s'attaque aux kosteniuk que
glee n'a à mon avis c'est la finale
avant l'heure on voit les gens parce que
vu comment elle joue les deux le train
pièce est une force que c'est mieux
qu'au sien ou non mais je sais pas mais
c'est quand on a le truc qu'on dit aux
minots c'est demain
c'est demain et il y aura gunino y aura
l'agglo et kosteniuk je pense mais la
lier aux sirènes ou par l intrigue mots
font qu'ils sont coupés ressemble il est
parti après la ronde 8e du top 12 pour
la rejoindre et va la préparer
donc oui partie des participants
pointent donc là il ya de nouveau un dan
dan des deux maris qui veut deux
nouveaux allaient faire fois ci ce nom
d'un gâteau aux jardins servent écoute
on va voir s'ils arrivent à 0,5 ça va
c'est la passe est un pas c'est didier
banquy 17 ans je serai pas les faire
cavaler alston cavaliers f4 que tahri
arica j'aurais laissé marie faire d'un
des deux fois 6 tu vois pas ce que
c'était clairement son plan si ça nous
est arrivé tard par les cinq
actuellement que de dominer la vie du
site affaires de 5 et le 4 c'est bien ça
des cases entrer des trucs cnr de fond
j'ai cinq et dix sept îles de sein qui
tombe la mort est la plus rock
ouais je vais s'évade vers l'au-delà
mahrer hills où je souhaite une qui
comprend pas en quoi c'est une erreur
d'échangés le foot cases noires du fian
kétou alors je vais revenir à la
position après dé prendre 5 des premiers
cinq fait tu vois le truc c'est que le
sait le mauvais food et noir et en fait
comme tu joue un rock de même de même
côté
dans cette position là tu pourras jamais
attaqué le roi noir c'est quasiment
impossible et donc en fait je fais que
venir échanger un mauvais coup contre un
bon fou et c'est même les noirs faut
souvent dans cette position là qui
veulent enfin qui perdent du temps pour
y arriver je suis tout nommé après je
peux comprendre ce soit un truc un peu
peut-être
notre logique de base que les footeux
qui inquiète au sélect a envie d
échanger mais pas dans ce cas-là quoi
y'a dame pro f 4 est bizarre cette
partie nord fait dam des deux tours des
limites se prendre dames c'est un art
fair dame va c'est la sarre fils un
tueur en un c'est pas bon pas bon qu'il
y avait un truc mais bon après que tu as
fait un trou dans les documentations
mais là c'est carrément sky averti qu'
il y en ait nigel short qui faisait ça
qui allait changer dans les pires cas il
faut acheter ce dont je t'ai pas cheap
affable ça dépend des pensions de la
position que ça dépend bon ben j'ai très
bien de quoi évidemment mais j'ai trois
plus ou moins forcée et là elle va faire
quoi rica va faire j'ai quatre noms j'ai
cassé un peu suicidaire n'ont d'autres
soucis ce que je gagne moins mais c'est
une partie c'est une partie femme un peu
alambiqué j'ai envie de dire bon ben ok
c'est peut-être aussi de convertir enfin
normaux dommage ça va mal ça pas mal
mais bon d'un machin crois j'ai 7
c'était un peu naïf je pense avec
énormément faire faut aussi un moment
donné je vous ai je pour s'ouvrir la
colonne est fait peut-être un peu de
contre jeu sur le roi 5 au moins le
temps tu as besoin que c'est fou
et on les fout ça donne toujours des
compensations mois elle envoie fat ce
qu'analysent c3 il est mal placé depuis
tout à l'heure il s'en va réparé il part
vers g3 est peut-être f5 h5 j'aime bien
scouts cavalier e 2 ok on peut pas juger
jouer dame me 3 bat bourse de ouais mais
j'ai pas j'ai rien j'ai pas un genre de
cavaliers des quatre sur foot france et
2 je le comprends ouais dame prend et
juan 37 17 vous gifi 3g 6 enfin il ya du
jeu quand même hein il ya du jeu fabing
france et de l afe tour euh ok de ouais
bon pourquoi pas pas mal aussi
elle se place sur la colonne sur la
colonne eux
j'émets une foule j'ai six noms pour wow
tours 8 ouais c'est plus fort dans ton
sens moi je veux faire bouger si c'est
éventuellement presse est préparée tour
8 mai fait pour 8 c'est pas mal ça crée
une madame des six bien vite qui est des
4 au 6 mai raison que les dégâts étaient
pas mal du tout abbas avait une bonne
tête quoi et là du coup du coup bah
ouais tous qualifiés dans les heurts
dans la vente
enfin c'est pas évident et en plus il
peut y avoir
suivant ce que les blancs jouent genre
cavaliers g3 et peut-être demain je pars
mejri peut-être fou des quatre noms je
voulais voir ce n'est pas carrément tour
point f de toi boum mais il ya des
preuves 5
mais oui donc vous des quatre et il y
aura un problème en place de sap en
échange des dames jeu le roi et c'est ce
qu'on va voir ce qu'elle peut tous les 4
as marre mais les attend il appartient
maintenant si elles prennent une
contemporaine s'assemble ça semble être
nul ça semble être le bon résultat pour
pour marie maintenant plutôt dans cette
partie mais bon faut des cas peut-être
prise de cette prise de cette leroy
peut-être pas trop de bonnes cases je
suis sûrement ouais mais peut-être on
peut reconnaître la tour enfin grand
roger six dont quatre mois j si j'avais
pas vu suite
bong attaqué la chance tu vaux vraiment
des ventes tensions autour de ce concept
mais je le sent pas le truc faut s est
déjà établie à pas fou prend f2 échec et
pouvait tout prouvé 3 way
bref de la fab à tous les regards des
premiers 3 je vous prends f2 froid price
de fou prend b3 mais s'arrêtent pour
prendre cet été elle le voit c'est ce
faire rage de sa rentrer là dedans on
met trois sets la finale fut très dur
soit de zèle des choses que je bouge de
partout
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que c'est le mauvais
scénario
fab genre sans que celle ci ait une
chance justement d'énormes foules mais
des foules et 3 alors la ford ont tous
les âges s'y prêtent vraiment le jeu
très vite mais ça ne s'était plus ou
moins je pense exactement la même chose
que toi femme je suis je me suis
elle-même la même relation jiva 5 et
forcé mais c'est 5 mais c'est vrai
qu'elle est elle a un peu mis le roi
noir à l'écart elle peut-être la tenir
quand même
peut-être à 5 maintenant roi ou trois
noms ça doit tenir fab ont vaincu les
jets 6.8 je pense à mes potes à cinq et
six saisons vont encore fait bref ces
quatre cas et 17 mai j'ai mieux géré à
56.8 n'aime pas faire cavalier à 6 ici
bas peut-être enfin quelle est cette
bombe à tout ce que j'ai dépensé 5,7
pouces leur vient bloquer les call
centers aux grossistes ou ce soir a
lancé 5 g pas embêté si cette façon tu
[Musique]
as cavaliers six échecs peut-être
kadhafistes cherchent à gagner dans un
choc avec m6 a gagné une pièce en un
oued hommage
c'est dommage on l'a pas vue directement
non plus un mais c'est dommage de rater
cavaliers fils quand même c'est c'est
vraiment très dommage surtout que ok
t'as un cavalier tu as une fourchette
c'est fait pour ce fait peut tu regardes
que ça quand tu joues ouais c'est
dommage
elle a dit que je regarde la chasse
trois mâles vous branchant reprend
maccione rsa développement à b5
croissance bon ça je 4 quand même tu es
tu sûr marie parlant il fait car tenez
votre parcours non mais c'est ok bon
mais elle a perdu en tant qu enfin cnt
prend 1,5 et penser 4 tu veux revenir
sacrifier d'avoir du bon jeu tenir
france mais c'est incroyable de la
partie n'en existe que fayçal qui ont
pas très précis d'accueil pour ses
quatre tu reviens tout tout à fait ça le
droit à sa fille carole trois retours
oui mais c'est facile avec elle cinq
c'est bien
non mais c'est euh ouais pas de mon
parti c'est pas n'est ce pas vrai entre
le ça crie ce machin de pions au début
perte de pions en un le machin mais
c'est assez c'est assez famélique non en
termes de niveau de jeu cette partie est
celle là était pas mal on arrive oui
bien sûr ça arrive mais c'est un peu
c'est dommage quoi acquis projet ça
c'est dommage que marielle a eu sa
chance et karelia pts 6 voilà c'est un
peu le cadeau tombé du ciel
ouais c'est dommage de rater des occases
comme ça si elle perd ce match est pour
un cadre regretté un les quelques
petites occasions que la safer qui a
conduit les additionne bon en fait même
bien là juste avec un million de pré
ouverture mentale même loin de ce
canular est juste finir non mais c'est
pour ça que je dis que dans le scénario
c'est quand même une partie qui est
parfaite pour elle mais l'a pour
l'instant ce sont de très bons le stand
du match à john wayne en je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec toi fab le scénario
me paraît on est on est vent de face et
on a toujours les petits problèmes
techniques pour pour redémarrer une
partie commence à se réfugier dans une
bordure
non mais tu pense vraiment qu'elle doit
ranger ses problèmes contre la pire
quand même ce que là encore un silo tu
le jeune champion et malin n'a pas le
temps de voir quelqu'un qui joue sa
bombe là dessus téléphone elle peut pas
jouer joueurs des caps ou chez moi non
parce que enfin gérard son père mais
juste pour pas qu'elle joue ça compte le
bien qu'on voit ou qu'elle fasse truc
avec grand roque et qu'elle envoie
jaloux fouet 3d de f3 g4 machin je peins
à patrick nhk ap vite
il ya plein de manager mais ouais mais
pas colza est elle prête juste la
position donc souffre trouver un point
faible dans le répertoire et tu peux pas
te laisser taper dessus tout le temps tu
année blanche bastoi kg tête
non mais je suis je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi fin juste à fait
d'accord dans l'autre joue là cela va en
premier mais au final même si elle joue
pas des quatre avec les blancs elle sait
se lavant premiers à les gérer plutôt
pas mal
parité noir et je voulais slave depuis
toujours à clément ader à ce répertoire
très très stable qui vous jamais sénat
je dors avec les blancs le cadre ouais
c'est bien donc elles te surprend pas
même connaît pas match qu'elle joue
enfin ça fait des années l'homme bien
bossé mais une fragilité sur la pire que
qui a été d c'est bon après ça je sais
pas tu as peut-être une fragilité dans
ce match de blitz et que et que voilà et
arica ça se trouve elle joue enfin dit
juste que je veux bien que vous entendez
ça tombe bien pour elle que ça marche
mais aujourd'hui je sais pas ouais mais
en tout cas ça se passe mal mais oui ça
ne va pas du tout a commenté jacques
clément je pars avec les mains sur ses
pieds elle peut elle peut se faire
braquer sur son service elle réussit pas
à mettre l'adversaire en danger
la gsa spirou par new de nouveau cessé
mais rang avec un temps de plus où les
blancs vont réussir à jouer c4 et avoir
une position des centres c'est rien de
grave
non là ils vont faire quoi les blancs y
prennent qui prennent une fois ils font
cavalier f3 vous pensez de ce voyage
on va retirer le chou c4 c4 et c4 est
peut-être sur fion français 4 tour à
tour segnora b5
ouais on est tous là justement arrive
également en retour c'est un rajoelina
cette non même pas non menace rien vos
menaces ou prend 1,6
bon vous dégagiez way écoute je préfère
les personnes en fait c'est bien par an
le 7h et 3 on concentre aussi la tour
eiffe des huit tours à ses 8 et la
position et sommes toutes égales ouais
c'est dommage du coup puisqu'en fait
avec les noirs elle se débrouille plutôt
bien elle égalise facilement elle a eu
des bonnes positions
elle a aucun doute celle qui stresse pas
trop bien alors donnez trop peut-être
j'ai mis quatre cavaliers h
quatre cavaliers f5 peut-être fou g6
romance attaque le 4
ça attaque 4 exactement cloud et s'est
défendu position qui est vraiment assez
symétrique punk et d du coup la question
qu'on peut se poser
on a indiqué lisa juste pour voir
l'agenda
ok ça assure qu'elle provoqua téké
pranger 6 bat du chronodrive 5
on a peur de jouer ok c'est pas grave
ici non non mais bon c'est déjà un petit
truc mais tu es là lourde un peu que les
affaires d'évasion
au final c'est un peu la même structure
que la pierre qu'elle se fait un peu
dominé les blessures de son envie cette
fois au 4ème génération carica elle
juste elle comprend mieux ses positions
là c'est l'impression que ça donne nos
[Musique]
pensées refoulées vite mais ouais tu
peux te faire des petits problèmes parce
qu'ils mangent vu plus loin les
contrôles mieux petite pression d'un
placé au centre de g4 un moment auquel
tout reprendre au quai ferry officiel et
reprend ses 8 f k des trucs comme ça
qu'ils peuvent
non mes petits machins qui voyageait 30
et le jeu g3e faire rager dauphin s'il
est juste elle va jouer vite des cours
sans rien vouloir faire particulier
mais du peuple et n'a vraiment pas grand
chose à faire il faut pas te faire
défoncer à la pendule manger deux des
coups comme ça faire des petits coups
qui qui qui paye pas de mine quoi mais
marie faut pas qu'elle ait envie de trop
s'active et tu auras ces genres de
pollution que je perds comme un idiot
souvent ça si je m'énerve en fait ouais
mais c'est dur de rien faire ce que
l'autre a l'impression qu'il fait des
trucs quoi ça t'énerve là moi aussi j'ai
le droit
by mais bon t'as le droit mais au final
ça se passe mal mais pas le mec tu n'es
gamine droite quoi préfère ça que je
trouve du temps fait coller une
20 46 of wales ou bien ouais
une dame des deux mais pas d'amener 3
mais aussi d'échanger du fait ensuite
double attaque
si tu fais dame d2 voire l échange d'amd
3par dont il va y avoir les changes en
d3 et tours et détours ses huit échecs
c'est pour ça qu'il faut à cette
peut-être ce me prépare quelque chose
c'est ça c'est très bien et tout fou tu
regardais deux mais ça va ça va tout à
fait ça va tout à fait au point de
transit même fou des quatre peut-être ce
que fout des quatre finales si on
échange et que je peux refaire ed je
suis heureux quoi me reste un combat 2d
ouais londonien je sais pas ou pour
animaux fait le tour
ça c'est cette m'inquiète bret padam
padam des deux coups têtu peut-être
tentés damage 5g pas on t'envoie mais on
tient peut-être prendre un point b c a
tué les pertes directes mais bon je sais
pas faim ça se perd pas dans le truc
mais si le temps en train de craquer là
j'aurais bien j'aimerais bien quand même
con là tu vois même pas cru qu'ils ont
choisi wemmel semi cracks belges tap tap
a envie de nom de venir ouais bah du
coup badham b3g pas tu continues à jouer
c'est assez pleutre ce qu'elle fait
qu'avec les blancs non mais tu vois
enfin j'ai quand même envie d'être un
peu entreprenant j'ai l'impression que
la partie tourne un peu en ma faveur
bon y'a rien mais bon crèche madame p 4
d'habitude c'est certainement ce que tu
les changes les dames n'est pas de
course et ce à tout coin restera tourner
le ps de donc les blancs font du tour
c'est demain truc comme ça et on tue ton
roi tu peux jouer là bas je te lis pas
trop mais je trouve que c'est dommage de
pas ne pas essayer tu vois de fin on est
quand même derrière dans le match après
s'il ya pas grand chose
il ya deux points mais j'aurais bien
aimé un peu m m 1,1 y casse le loup
voilà enfin pas il a écouté le stream au
français
je change je change mon fils ah ah oui
partie annulée parce que c'est la
garenne et cinq minutes fab donc les
mais c'est pas grave on déjà ça montre
que peut-être moins on va peut-être
jouer la vente que tu veux sur la pire
qu un char de fenoyl exactement donc
fable à ce qui va se passer en gros
c'est qu'il fait parce que tu as vu de
ton micro on va faire cinq minutes de
pause battue peut muter toi même alors
non parce qu'en fait je vais mettre de
la musique
donc du coup si je te mute jeu mu tout
en fait en même temps mais je pense que
tu devrais trouver en fait je mette une
pub et je vais mettre de la musique tu
vois très intéressante occasion je
trouvais le vent levé je sais parler de
contourner plus qua non sur ton est plus
bon femme du couple a tout de suite fait
me poser ensuite minutes ouais
[Musique]
dans l'eure fab on est de retour
nouvelle cadence 3 plus une ouais bon ça
pas encore prise non mais mais ça doit
reprendre incessamment sous peu puisque
on a les caméras qui sont lancés et il
suffit que je le dise pour qui un bug
mais ça ne lancez pas dans le golfe
point ça ok c'est maintenant elle joue
mais je dis bien content de son
amphithéâtre et la santé oms et du coup
elle rejoue la pire que mais c'est bien
ça était prête à jouer le bon truc
ouais mais ça va retomber au kef watches
peut-être aux plus tôt c'est peut-être
mieux ou pas bon ben nan mais je pense
que si elle prend pas en hausse 1
qu'elle garde un coût de l'argent si
elle fait grand roque le bessin besoins
de la personne
et je vais changer les noms peuvent
échanger en d4 comptage ou h3c la règle
parce que quand on écrit ces cinq
attaques cap
tu dois faire et ce sera pour défendre
et a pas envie quoi on te lâche 3 et
hashtag parise
mais bon ok je prends des quatre juste
après le creusement et c'est pour ça que
je dis que le x fi se fait plus sens
maintenant sans avoir échangé à eux 5
je suis d'accord mais vous verrez que je
ferai c'est un gage à mon poids de faire
des quatre bombes et cette chance et
justin je pense pas que ce soit très
grave est grand en réalité j'ai pas
programme on était un peu en pls par
rapport par rapport aux occasions ratées
mais il ya que moins de fab widness le
score et rien de fait mais si je te fais
une image qui est chiant voilà pas green
party gagne pas mais elle était pas loin
il aurait fallu qu'il fait elle aurait
juste vu la fourchette s'était fait quoi
c'est ça s'est pas joué à grand-chose à
un couperet là comme souvent à un coup
près le couperet était tombé exactement
alors une histoire à 10,6 de force
pire qu'ils y fassent signe de match
employés doivent pas le player arica
réalise tout est un film de pierre ouais
en fait ils t'explique ouais c'est la
quatrième pire c'est que les phillies
une faille déjà eu quatre pires le truc
officielle mais qui met il pas les
écrivains qui écrivent mais qui écrit
ben mc écrit là en dessous ou créez
votre vide jeudi qu'elle mène deux et
demi heure et demie dans la pierre
jusqu'à maintenant l'état de dessin ou
changent comme le conte stratégie tu
penses des cinq direct bah je veux tu
échanges et appelé des 6 ou tu fasses
les cinq toiles je devais le fond des
cinq je vire madame idiots qui s était
pas idiot de les dépouiller
peut-être des charges jusqu'à ces deux
qui peut qui traîne à la fin dans le cas
que d'un bref allait faire avant bon
allez on peut envoyer des 5
je sais pas trop ce nom mais ça peut
aller regarde ses dessins qui fait qu
avec les noirs je prends j'aurais reflet
puis on prend oui mais tu enlèves le
foot avec les racistes fait ça je
voudrais aller rendre dans la petite
finale comme non comme témoin ouais
j'aime bien cette petite finale
mais bon l'après tour euh non autour du
thème français 7 et il ya peut-être 58
donc ouais faut encore être précis pour
pour les noirs là c'est sympa c'est
plutôt pas mal
on ne peut pas faire jusqu'à va les
prendre 5 en fait je vous comprends
woodham prend d'ailleurs encore mieux
plus facile encore du coup tu prends ces
sept et tu fais tu leur donnes des
quatre gardes le cloud est à raison
d'années cas c'est super bien joué fab
cavalli aussi sait on ce bar
complètement quand on va en c4 par
exemple c'est tant mieux
ecoute-moi pas cracher dessus du col à
faire quoi qu'ils aient g8 qui a eu 7 et
17 qui avait fuite web alors peut-être
faire du tour des six sous donc les
bletterans sécurisé
bon il faut prévoir chaussures la
pendule et qu'on retient gagné une
partie pour le moment la pendule ça va
elle a peut-être un petit coup de tours
c4 je suis dit oh oui mais ça anormal
maaf pas les tours 7 et 10 ans kelly si
on peut pas on partout quoi tu veux pas
faire payer des six mois c'est foutu ok
il faut jouer encore oui mais vous
faisait 1 6 4 bref si cette annonce a
fait mal j'ai cinq dossiers sacoche
propose pas une fourchette un truc qui
va traîner
bah oui mais il faudra la faire quoi
quand tu sais c'est qu'en dix ans la
fourchette
c'est juste que tout à l'heure on l'a
eue la fourchette mais cahill 6 3 c'est
dommage un alaïa puis on prend et au
rejet si ce nom vous êtes cas contraire
tout reprend mais oui ça allait bien
pour prendre ça que tu n'as autour des
tours kiev 6 et alors qu'en dormant pas
tu peux même f6 s'est pas battus on
prend ce qui est intéressant est ouverte
à fourche à toit d'un garage
bah oui ce que je voulais faire en fait
non c'est pas plus riche de la hmg
d'europe
ouais mais nous avons le meilleur demain
conclut par brun way
oui bah oui tu avais la même avec mon
premier fils henri iv a non seulement
elle peut elle peu l'arnaqué à mon avis
un ouf 37 6 3 monte wave saint calais ça
peut passer fab a bien joué pour ses 5
c'est bien joué la finale de pions ok
mais d'être sur détroit et peut-être que
pour ces 3 ou chez ces trois mètres c3f
on revient un peu juste car on peut
prendre b 3 qui est dé 6,3 fuite
alors je n'en fais une fois pas deux un
cash 500 m²
dougan
non elle va la sauver reprocher mais ça
a failli passer la fourchette 1 mais la
tour b 4 et la finale le gagnant mais
encore une fois dommage de profession
c'est dommage de laisser filer cgc filer
une victoire c'est prend des cinq way la
ccra cajun ouais alors c'est pas si
grave parce que c'est une femme peu
importe il ya des chances que bon leur
actuel fait au sein qu'elle fait mardi
inversée je pleure trop se dit ou fait
pas le dossier vide ouais je suis en
train de je suis en train de penser au
fait qu'au final elle marie allait s'y
situent 6e et truc elle peut même être
devant ça ça joue vraiment à rien donc
il faut pas se décourager femmes
ben non mais plus aujourd'hui une cause
juste non mais si elle commence à gagner
une ou deux parties ça peut aller vite
surtout qui allie à la section bull est
derrière les 38 de bullet ça peut ça
peut enchaîner dans le bon sens mais
c'est inquiétant parce que dans le petit
jeu tactique à rick a quand même l'air
d'être beaucoup plus affûté ça fait que
se confirmer pour le moment
et puis ma place est courte plus monté
sur ce genre de le projet mais mais
après ça peut ça peut aussi jouer dans
la tête et 6,6 mari gagne 2,3 parti ça
peut complètement inverse la tendance à
dire que votre pédagogie pour expliquer
pourquoi cette fois ci tu n'as pas son
âge ce n'est pas parce que là du coup le
fou g7 briller sur la diagonale alors
que tout à l'heure ils étaient dix
avaient un pion aux cinq et ils étaient
bloqués quoi c'est très pédagogiquement
donc cette position finalement est
complètement complètement corrects pour
les noirs même pas
c'est un et audemars auxi les dames sont
échangées position complètement il ya eu
de souci j'ai l'impression qu'elle va
trop ce qu'elle va avec peut-être même
quoi ça va faire ce que sur des quatre
qu'on peut donc gagner un pion ouais
c'est cool tout défoncer ouais c'est
bizarre mais fo f1 peut pas jouer un
truc genre la saison donc il faut que je
rentre je pense ff3 cta temps chez nec
leucate situe cloud oui oui 4 x 4 je te
tue ouais tu vas juste gagner un pion là
nan mais je pense que j'ai eu quatre des
cats
bush
scipion tranquille et 3 pour prendre les
trois tours prend des quatre oeuvres
ça va prendre
nash l'attaqué des trois îles pour
garder les trois français trois tours en
d4
j'ai bien couru 81 ok bon bah on va
juste préparé on oublie toujours ta
juste tour des pour des stades pour
beissat c'est bien suffisant si on fait
peut-être tour bessette puisque tours 17
est un an et du faux h3 mais je sais pas
si ça apporte vraiment quelque chose on
s'en fout complètement peut-être répond
il me prend deux fois je crois et crise
était de faire kébé saint caprais trucs
comme ça
georget tour 17 fois sur la fois je
crois que peu souffert f140 ailleurs
c'est de la merde en fait donc je vous
pensez du programme
si mobilise un peu autour f5 vêtements
etc et dessins on fixe non mais les
mieux mais il faut remarquer marc vella
c ces cours du groupe le prétoire des
huit des cats est très dur à défendre
l'indéfendable n'ont juste pas possible
et du coup à la france est un pion après
taton vous octroie hyper fort qui
fédérer volume a donc sa paire
d'attaquants ce sujet donné c'est vrai
je n'ai pas le temps de faire g5 g4s que
[Musique]
j'attends c'est 8 mai bon juste ok
d'être échangé le fou pour des visites à
la loupe les andes et un petit bond de 3
g 5 4 mais toujours évident dans ces
quatre points de vue sur 5 ha tu
préfères est donc le roi g5 f4 une fois
les vitres ou juste la pression autant
et peut-être à 5 à 4 aussi un moment
donné on a juste elle craint rien volé
c'est important ouais je pense tu peux m
tu mets du vrai tu mêleront f6 un pion
f4 laurent f5 fait à 5 à 4 et après tu
vois tu vas 5 à 4,3 aussi ce même tour b
5 3 des 5 tu as they say peut-être même
de les convaincre pour dessein que l'on
puisse vraiment froide et 6 et on mettra
la tour en b3 mais on avance et on
n'avance pas non tu méfiance kg en f4
pion à 4 3 au 6 e tour b5 d53 machin tu
mets retour en b3 et on était quand même
très bien après mes trois courses et
trois autres cadres
je pense f4 fab mais juste faut jouer un
poil plus vite la forêt visibles toutes
les vitres se solde en avant parce que
l'attrait des faux élargir la pression à
la position à la pendule partout partout
et surtout les asie milliards total
s'adjuge richement suffire wife 5 1
bon pour financer ces quatre c'est très
heureux en fait tant des trottoirs des
trois ans c'était bien mais c'est
bizarre pour ces cas secondaires juste
logique
ouais mais c'est peut-être très bien en
fait ce que tu gagnes l'option non mais
moi j'aurai fait tour c4 aussi fait bon
ben j'ai trois temps tu peux pas faire f
ranger 3 prises des deux échecs genre la
finale de pions bon là des deux échecs
quand même tu as envie non non non ouais
mais bon coup de foudre
oui non mais oui tu as raison des deux
c'était pas terrible mais si on va
gagner ce qui va arriver on saura
changer le truc à faire tout recette là
peut-être seignosse à 6 échecs renard
mais tombée c'est 3-3 et jacques google
construisent des châteaux et mais chaque
échec la sa total à 7
et on va déjà trois mois alors à temps
est-ce que je peux réussir à faire quoi
que ce soit
michel
aucun nom j'arrive pas à trouver non
plus ok mais la guerre froide et de jean
baqué droite bandée donné le 3 reprend
le 3e tour ses rangs et entre sagem ok
ça c'est une tentative des trois rois
ces trois baies de rois des reines n'ya
rien n'y aura rien non mais d'euros
cette dame tour prends ton prince est
nul c'est assez dommage quand même de
rater ça c'est trop je pense c'est ces
dommages sont un peu grasse avait trop
de noms mais sur ses lignes finale mais
tour des trois ça sentait le coup un peu
bizarre j'en retour ces cas je suis
continue à progresser et tout est en
fait le truc rap c'est toujours pareil
dans ces finales là enfin si tu
maintiens cette pression là non
seulement bon tu m'as intérêts pression
et et améliore sa position non plus à
tout moment tu peux avoir un truc
complètement gagnant cas ce que je veux
dire genre tu maintient la pression
d'une gaffe tu joue juste vite et bien
tu joue vite bien et tu mets la pression
autant et tu vois tu es tu gagnes tu
gagnes tu as des conseils de mur tu as
quoi elle conseille très simple très
pédagogique
tu joues vie tu joues bien tu gagnes tu
arrêter au bout d'un moment c'est pas
compliqué les échecs pajero vertus joue
vite et bien c'est tout
mais ça doit être dur d'en arrière avec
les premiers froids et des cinq volets
de bonnes chances non mais faut rater ce
qui est d'être enfin je dirais pas que
c'est un mauvais coup dans l'absolu mais
ça marche trop mal dans ce match j'ai
notamment paul bachy
on rit à 4,6 va pas trop là dedans non
[Musique]
c'est cruel la fab bas bon le réalisme
c'est important ouf
il peut à coup foot et crs important
dans tous les indices dans tout un tas
balles de break je t'avais un balle de
break dans le match quand ton converti
aucune
de folie / / / lesure le circuit circuit
asiatique
c'est un nadal garcia-lopez ou kezman
est en fait nadal face à un des rares
matches qu'il a perdu contre 1 du
magnoac domine complètement
en fait je compte y cirad 28 balles de
break d'affilée quoi c'était peut-être
28 j'exagère mais c'était plus de 20
genre tu peux tu un câble et la zéro sur
22 et à la fin du match j'ai dit ok mais
si tu es incapable de guînes balles de
break ou non non c'est plus possible
bah oui non mais en plus si on a
certaines ok il a mal joué ou quoi il y
en ad'autres ses ballets t'as faim tu
assez fou par contre au 3 mai en fait au
moment où tu peux être un plomb et là
c'est un peu la même chose
notre taux de 5 aces 85 attention mais
voilà c'est pas la cata la position
juste pas sûr que le distinguer des six
ainsi tranchant tania fait là attention
attention le chien fou 17 tours 8
non mais ça va encore marie qui peut
faut pas qu'elle se fasse trop distancer
puisque pour le moment quand même fable
le davantage entre guillemets c'est que
ces partis elle les rate mais les perd
pas elle fait nul donc elle n'est pas
trop distancées tu vas malgré les
ouais bon trois points c'est pas non
mais je sais que tu es en vie quoi faut
pas minable en tant que tant que
mathématiquement c'est jouable
par ailleurs trois points à gerland il
reste combien de temps ils restent là et
c'est pas le temps je ne sais pas mais
l'accord dont il doit rester 48 2 3
puisse enfin tu peux tu peux tu peux
bien tourner dame prend à cette voie là
tu un pion +1 voilà ça c'est vérifiable
bon je prends mon ouais tu manges
bessette ouais bon j'ai quatre rouges
tous eu notre eu à manger la 4ème
prendre j'ai six heures très intéressant
non mesdames f k tu pas sûr du nom parce
qu'on voit bien ce à quoi bon ok je sais
pas ce que arrêter de se faire dame
prend 1,4 à me prend bessette est ok bah
au moins je suis pas à 5 ans voire à 5 à
6 à 5 à 6 et si tu prends à 6 je
mangerai les six jeux tendent des pièges
mais bon la production du tout ouais bah
voila c'est un bon un jeu au retour au
stade sûrement jamais la vue vite elle
est bonne dans le petit à petit jeu
tactique 1 du coup ok bonté d'âme des
huit ça sert à rien non le zinc ou cinq
arrêts non plus mais c'est un coup c'est
bien mais bon en conception et les noirs
prendre quatre on a trop apprécié cette
attention
ouais le problème en fait c'est juste
que oui et noir sont pas mieux mes tubes
the economist de moi et tous rêvent
quatre là et c'est un souci bateau reste
quatre ça fait mal ça va
bon après tout on tv 5 à 6 mai suivant
ps
il faut défendre ainsi dur bon alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut tenter peut-être on
fait des cinq tours j'ai cinq jeux toi
j'aime pas trop réussi ce faux ici pas
mal aussi bon à tout faire à 6 par an
voyez en fait sont partis pour partie
faut envoyer aller l'envoya dallas on
voit qu'on leur connaît un beau alors ok
à tout rachat où elle va prendre h est
entouré de quatre pourquoi ouais écoute
j'aime bien ma trace je m'entoure à
quatre fers du coup il va y avoir quoi
c'est pas mal joué
est-ce que ça non bon on est pro on sait
rien et l'a donc tu veux dans ses
fichiers fou sur le champ ou offrant les
tours ne me prendrait 5
ouais mais tu as à me 5 à l'intention
d'être annoncée et à la main cinq
cadavres cinq fables fait d'aveux 5 ça
se goupille pas mal c'est toujours
déconnectés et ça tourne the est fou
c'est don pouvait pas faire croire
c'est avec l'idée de la sale [ __ ] ou 5
hier matin fabien matt pas besoin de
soirée 5
ouais avec la dame aurait foncé de thé
je voulais c'est vrai fait roi en disant
si tu prends quoi quoi qu'il en soit
j'ai des cinq échecs y avait peut-être
moyen de tournicoter abord il ya des
thèmes saga qui lance hilare m
francophones en parallèle du speech s à
oui ça on peut la mettre ça je peux vous
l'organiser
si vous voulez la joue et je peux le
faire si vous voulez faire la reine
francophone je peux vous le faire c'est
vrai du coup on peut la faire je vais je
vais la mettre
je vais mettre un tout petit peu plus
tard du coup c'était pas prévu mais je
vais la mettre
ouais 20h45 20h50
top 45 20h55 et 20h58 brat heures
carnahan 20h45 c'est bien en tant qu
ancien bagne 1,5 ouais on va la mettre
pendant une heure
aujourd'hui 20h45 pas le contrôle
doivent être cinq minutes standard arena
chester et france duré une heure c'est
parti c'est une bonne initiative si ces
petits loulous et clamant l'arête amiens
gens plein de gens se connecter qu'ils
sont amis avec moi il ya des mains de
partout ouais c'est pas mal paraître se
reconnaître quoi mais du coup je
n'accepte plus que les défis des gens
qui ont des mains enfin oui bah tu vas
pas d'un dommage à un peu de chocolat
ouais alors france avec 18,4 sévère mais
juste bas je suis d'accord avec françois
jacq c'est sévère mais d'un autre côté
si tu ne peux pas gagner une finale et
que tu te faire arnaquer une fois sur
deux fins et hilton kim ans je te faire
le point de villard de lans pas cette
année mais peut-être au prochain ces
années je vais encore ce je retourne à
porticcio partick porticcio je n'ai raté
que c'est super n'en reviens pas mal de
joueurs français y avait eu délit qui va
jouer aussi je scelle les purs grain et
là tu as une nouvelle fois c'est
intéressant d'échanger le foot case
noire parce qu'il ya une vraie idée
offensive d'attac pour les blancs sur le
roc un tout 21 tu veux m'intégrer
tu prends danger saturday nos deux
matchs 6v d'ailleurs je pense que
personne ne se projette en c2 prend de
l'âge 6 4 6 il ya qualifié 5e d'amour on
achète aussi leur dans les dom dont je
trouve ce film tomber un nombre
probablement d'un des deux mais je
voulais te dire je vais profiter pour
bien au sein
j'aurais fait dam des deux mais je
voulais proposer comme idée parce qu'en
fait tu mens tu as dame des deux qui
menacera lecavalier quoi mais du coup
y'a qu'ça rim afin d'amener de ces
écoutes a envie de faire tempo mais
c'est chaud
sagan combiner deux choses oui mais
enfin j'aurais fait tempo en fait ce que
tu menaces tourbe et un ebitda manger
sain où a eu lieu le 5 avril
5 bon alors à temps wafo f1 c'est le
plus simple enquête cinq tours prend des
4 et 17 fourchette de totem prénoms des
deux états il faut enfin très bien
rajoelina pour paris c'est fini alors
battu peut vous fait car elles tiennent
youtube du bouveret le 5 ans prend
d'accueil et des statuts pro b 6 quand
tu te fais prendre des dommages au
québec ça l'était encore plus bon il
faut autre chose qui doit être très bien
aussi j'imagine à la faire quelque 5000
à laquelle s'attelle à tour les
compagnies pas le vuc retrouver ce n'est
pas une précis parce qu'elles vont
répondre pour ça tu mens je fais de toi
bah oui je fais tour ses sept tours 4
c'est ça un report en d2 mais oui je
pense que je t'aime plus précis oui mais
enfin tout gagné wen ont enfin non penin
non mais qu'elle prend des 3 et qu'elle
prend à mais quand il prend des 3 lanes
en couple c'est génial en fait mary qui
marie qui revient ces impressionnantes
pas gagné ça quand même
c'est incroyable elle peut quand même
encore soirée c'est le bon c'est
tellement un miracle sur paris ce truc
tu veux juste faire le vide you français
kader direct et avec quatre cavaliers 5
par les sépare incroyable on va
peut-être se prendre congé 6 août un
gamin d'entre eux marchaient
progressiste en pro b cette dame
grossistes et chaque mois elle le voit
pas allez allez encore dans l'ain dans
le game elle est encore dans le gave fab
mais on fait un bon geste
17la j'aime pas être et nitro est ce que
tu veux mais le truc c'est que la menace
franges et 6 quand même un peu moche ça
d'un coup je sais pas fin juste part et
les menaces
ouais tu peux pas faire peut-être cp
numéro cinq mondial sion larouche est
j'aime pas ça ça on va faire confiance
mais rangé si sa prise dame prend tout
rejet d'un projet chrome os est pris à
tort prend 17 la ouache un peu dans les
gradins prendre mais non le prince
william en deux tours et on prend des
essais tu vois quoi toi dans le froid le
nom meilleur des métiers d'art à la
madame son ami et peut-être perpète
il y avait dames 1 il ya des messieurs
dames est roi bongo bienvenus il ya le
père pète via les tournois est ce que
j'allais dire tout retard pour éviter
d'un bref de quoi tourner autour c'est
normal pour prendre un prendre boujou
juste formidable et j'ai entouré en
rouge attend et on peut pas faire
d'alger six tours j'ai sept tours au 8
avec les blancs tu veux mais pour
prendre aux 7èmes prendre une approche
ouais mais bon voilà trois mois
qu'est-ce que ça bah oui mais j'ai créé
une superposition non parce que le fou
bessette palmarès fait rien pour le
moment au journal as dommages sis
toujours au final oui pourquoi pas nous
se sentent tous les pions mais elle
pense que la clé quand je crée nul parce
que juste tu as trois ratés et humaine
de quatre points seulement prendre des
risques et de points de pression et
contraction je laisse tomber la pendule
mais bon on a quand même raté un bon
ouais là elle a raté un et de face
c'était c'est tout gagné quoi elle
faisait juste france et quatre ans et
quatre cavaliers 5 et c'était
élémentaire de jeu efficace oncle elle
va elle va jouer quatre mais justement
je crois
même là tu dois envoyer enfin ça va ça
notre langue
bref c'est autre chose
bon tant pis si facile si quelqu'un peut
mettre la reine le lien de l'aréna
francophone c'est cool les mecs et ça et
que tu as il ya cinq inscrits pour le
moment il ya trois mecs avec les mains
quoi ne masquent une porte assez bien
ses mains toi tu la mise au pas déjà moi
je vais pas demain sa famille devaient
encore tu vas prendre la cale juste
devant moi j'ai ma tête mais tu vas être
humain je m'attaque ouais t'as le droit
je vous en plus d'être commun ouais
c'est plus la tête moment après et ont
divers est intelligent du coup tu peux
mettre un pied un de chasse qui vont
rentrer chez soi comme chez moi je vous
appelle et j'espère même quand je suis
taillé check point comme je suis
quelqu'un de jazz comme je disais 'j'ai
slugz ils comprennent pas notre présent
ça le fait marrer
du coup je m'appelle lélex face à ces
même pas drôle coiffe intéressés et
qu'opus quoi blunt
ce n'est pas une blague coiffe un
bonjour abat jour voilà un jeu de mots
un jeu de mots laids qu'on n'y
paraissent se rendent la merde en fait
c'est génial bon alors cette partie se
passe rien pour l'instant
mais le pire est à venir si ce cas est
un cas les files en pied alès en fait je
pense à x martin écrit perez mais en
fait les pieds à l'ess c'est pas parce
que le grand jean meyer qui n'est pas
mieux il ya quelqu'un qui te disent ah
non lui ces malades qui répondent qu'ils
répondent françois jacq
ah ouais
ouais
ludwig grosse de faire une manoir pour
moi façon fantômas bah écoute pourquoi
pas on verra aussi si tu as le temps que
tu veux me faire un p'tit truc c'est le
plaisir et il a beaucoup de temps à
exiger une main perso mais plein demain
après à prendre toutes les mains sont à
prendre
en fait les gens pourront prendre ta
main quoi s'ils font une main ta main
sera non je le copyright sera
téléchargeable mais toutes les mains
c'est comme les pieds quoi la tête et
les jambes
du coup bon ça passe très mal ce match
bah ouais c'est ça on a un peu on a un
peu dans le dur pas parce que parce que
c'est on est déçus quoi va palmarès ya
une joueuse française dans le truc
au premier tour on est en train de se
faire battre par une indienne qu'enfin
j'ai envie de te dire nulles
qu'est ce que c'est que ça fo froid je
crois qu'il va y est froid qui arrive
cela va non mais en plus c'est faria
fait qu' on prend quand même sur des
emprunts et quand même fou prend je
crois gfr les peuples turcs ont vu que
tu vas lire c'est bien ou en option
longtemps leur odeur non mais faut
réagir la cia +4 s'est pas encore fini
ce match non pour mais là jusqu'à mon
dieu je pense que prendre aux
ambassadeurs et d'amd 6 waouh peu
importe h45 si elle joue vite mariko
juste des coûts sont naturellement
naturel oui naturel en belgique d'un des
six prétendants à l'investiture c'est
sûr qu'avec gestion qui vont s'ouvrir en
énorme b3 il va dominer par et ça c'est
un rat table non
allez c'est pas possible à tuer la tour
en d1 tu finis tout les rentables mais
tu laisses pas les noms ça va lui à
tingwick y ait un casque bleu des
causses à un tour a changé
j'aurais peut-être fait kg 3 tu vois ce
après on croit retrouver trois fous de 6
ans rentre de pins où on est deux on est
là quoi on te met la tête sous l'eau
salée à montana qui commence ici tu y
crois pas propre à aller tous les trois
pas mal aussi à la tour qui arrive bien
vite française comme ces quatre bombes
en plus apte à le plan des feuilletons
étrangers 4 h 5 roger 6 2 partout il
faut vous allez roi bref trois là c'est
peut-être pas mal mais bon je n'ai juste
jouer plus vite ouais c'est ça le truc
il fallait un poil plus vite fable fois
ci c'est quand même fort ok mon oncle ou
un bon là l'autre à la plus aucun coup
elle peut pas jouer presque avec et noir
non on vous attends c'est cet appel va
faire un tour à tour à s'être ses 16 ans
mais rien n'oblige à manger 3 le roi tu
pense qu'il va où il enrage 6 6 4 faire
le tour des cinq mois le roi prenant un
ciseau tout tout tout va bien roger 4 1
je pense tu montes tu montes autour des
adjoints paralysé à l'étranger vêtements
qui seront à table se libère ways je
peux le couple le problème c'est bizarre
manqué c'est peut-être encore gagnant 1
c'est moins gagné à benfica pour les
jeux partout où tu me font des 5
mais bon quel tour à un machin tu dois
en crotte mieux mais a tout de même
perdu ne peut pas toi entaché pessah de
la faire non mais t'es gagnant mais
juste gagner sans rien faire quasiment
ça a quand même gagné là je pense et du
joug pesant que dans l'air tour ses huit
noms dont assad a aussi ses petits pots
ouais c'est pipo inzaghi tout ça tombe
essonne ok mais un an et cavani qui
arrive et c'est un peu dangereux fab de
gens tomber sa part dangereux ouais ça
rien de dangereux
non mais oui à l'efa première victoire
après
après quoi après deux heures et demie
deux 2 matchs première victoire
voilà c'est le déclic ouais ça peut être
le déclic attendu h 5 h 4 l et on lui
rentrer dedans on en a marre ou non mais
je pense qu'elle aura intérêt à lui
rentrer dedans fait par exemple juste la
défonce et verizon qui s'est vite que
vos comptes du fragment moi je sais pas
grand chose un trou d'homme c'est 8 h 54
oui oui bon je fais ça tu gagnes pas tu
gagnes pas non plus quoi mais je le fais
c'est vrai a déjà fait plus dans
l'esprit ouais non mais allez je sais
pas moi d'amd sa c5
allez on voit quoi voilà les pions à les
renvoyer la fin de ta raison mais ça on
est très heureux très huit coups
s'enchaînent c'est le rwanda qui se
dessine mais il peut y avoir un mental
en plus dans le sens où elle est
vraiment pas loin peut-être des quatre
la femme je ne sais plus je ne parle
plus de coups juste jouer vite et bien
voilà non mais je ne crois pas t4 du
probable mais avait grandi capturant des
400 voix au moins tu la mets sous
pression quoi on veut aller vers bessin
elle y est elle en train de craquer
fable marcheuse indienne la partie me
peux juste prendre toutes les qualités
et le pas gagné ouais
est ce un tournant par mail aurait
vraiment pu tout manger fabre c'était
impressionnant
tout ne tourne plus c'était incroyable
tout était comestible absolument tout ce
qui me semble aussi elle avait marqué
neuf ni loi et c'est ça la marque et
notre nul et une victoire
cinq points et demi la finul c'est
beaucoup quoi bon alors je vois sur la
caméra le console descendront ouais elle
tombe c'est le signe d'un cessez le sang
avait poussé in a way après j'aime pas
trop les noirs en perse au taquet ce
qu'ils nous disent à temps je dis des
trucs guen 14 ans et baxter swing tu
ailles te dise première victoire et te
disent que l'ordinateur te faisais une
projection qui avait gagné le bullet de
pas plus un marais attention oui mais
avant le match s'enlise
bah oui mais bon ça me rase algorithmes
en fait un long moment il a eu raison de
tous les matchs qu'il a maintenant
commencé il a eu un rush en fait ça
c'est génial qu'on pensait que c'est un
génie qui prévoyait tout et puis c'était
qu'un roche
mais l'abbé 5 c 4
et ouais mais bon
b 5e 5 et et puis on prend bien oui mais
c'est pas grave fab h4 peut-être h 30
des machins comme ça non mais tu prends
b4 en fait finalement finir les dégâts
ouais
tant pis un bon tant pis tomber pareil
je défends les cinq bons ces moments
très forts de bouffer gagne aussi ça
fait loin cette fois je crois
ces problèmes n'est pas mais cb une fois
et amassé trois prises prisé dame ces
trois débats autour de 30
pas tant pis je prends des psychiatres
au prince et un problème c'est 4 et puis
et puis je vois pas mon repos - au
travers de la pression répond d'une dame
c'est 6,12 à faire tourner sa couette
hors des cinq tours d un essai 7 il faut
tant des deux je pense
il faut aussi qu'elles utilisent bien la
seule clameur de l'échiquier avec les
blancs donc forcément les bons souvenirs
la perte foot à cette colonne qui plombe
les détours et à le fou qui va les
orages trois ordinateurs petite pression
par ci par là h5 peut-être amen
c'est un peu chiant je vais franchement
pour des ces tâtonnements
ok c'est la vie quoi ok ce qu'elle peut
tenter planter ses torts et 7 kg 6 h 5
qui est des câbles mais même ça j'aime
battre nancy va s'éprendre des quatre
dom prend des stades c'est bien mais 4
ans et 5
c'est bien joué de sa crise de calloc'h
de l'aric ah ouais ok mais je n'en rien
dans tout ça c'est bien beau mais là
nous mêmes parties la radio il faut
ajouter trois jeunes femmes ou d'autres
fois je trouve elle va prendre russie
aussi bien obligé en fait mine mais pour
le moins tu as encore fou prend est
tombé fou un machin foutais nature
reprend 1,5 mais très mal et du cou à
ces rencontres sont plus quatre direct
des dommages de pas faux tickets sur ce
week end la partie d'avant mais la juge
a fait de même par tina cas mais on
compte six ans mais il ya de fous 17600
premier tour 17
on vous prête sa voix aux siens en bas
je savais plus en plus ça gagne aussi 1
milliard f 4 500 voix les pions pour
nous bon on remarque attaque à trois
bassins
ouais t'as encore un peu de chemin qu'il
est encore un et tu as il suffirait
d'une étincelle aurait probablement des
cinq qu'elle va faire nul n'ont pour
seule frappe exploit qu'elle a plus de
temps les gens prison quelle autre c'est
incroyable l'important quand on mène à
tout je suis renversé faible et l'a52
juste bon c'est pour aller mais
peut-être j'ai l'impression quand elle
commença pas trouvé qu'elle a peu de
temps elle peut paniquer non on m'aide à
30 secondes ouais mais bon si bas
qu'elle s'attaquera cote quoi fab
mais bon là c'est nantes bat étonné dans
tu te reconnais c'est les mecs
il lui dit qu'il nous met des slips s et
des échos plus dans le tchat
c'est nouveau mais méconnu ouais pas mal
non sipes pour robert s celanese pour
repérer son slip s quoi beaucoup de sms
pique sa vis à vis ou chat il faut il
faut des six pasqua ils sont heureux bon
alors cette petite allée keane ça se
passe plutôt pas mal pour marine ans
c'est pas je pense quoi ça se passe
quand même fab l'un bien bien grand mot
mais peut-être qu'à idée si cela tu vas
se baissa tfc est quand même mais il
peut y avoir un jour dieu 4 qui te
contre des choses comme ça mais pourquoi
pas vous parfois ça a pas l'air si mal
je sais plus trop à quel saint se vouer
ouais mais bon ça qu'est bon mais
s'attelle veut faire aux quatre jeux
sans nuages ont fait h3 je vous fais
chier mais maintenant je dérange pas
direct oui mais il faut chaque fois je
tiens quand même où je vous promets 3g à
free qui valait à cinq mois plus tôt qui
traîne au mas je crois oui bon c'est pas
grave non sa tournée des huîtres et
fuite en dégage et son cavalier de paix
je fais tu as tu fait faux faux 3 ici en
fait que si tu prends je prends deux à
moi je pense que vous nous manquons
bientôt c'est une probable donc à tomber
cette loi va défendre nous qu'un 3e
division ouais c'est un peuple autres
[Musique]
aujourd'hui retour maintenant je fais
mes 50 pour les choses que vous jetez
pib 5 km et 5 j'attaque de l'autre côté
de la new way mais non mais
sur ce thème tutorat garde pour les
blancs objectivement tâte perd deux
tours des cantonales elle dame
alors je sais 5,5 c'est peut-être pas
mal hein ça ça ça a le mérite de poser
un peu des questions auxquelles je peux
pas faire qui avale signé le 4 bah non
non tu mens sur échec avec et b5 du coup
même maintenu le lecavalier bsi ses
protégés ou quand j'entreprends nom
d'emprunt à 6 ouais sûrement quitter
c'est ça ton truc comme ça pour mes
courses ici était traqué prend b3 après
longtemps pour tempo poursuivi cgil à
tanger pas fou fawcett tu fais quoi
cavalier prend b3 fou prend f6 qui est
point fou pranger cette non tu vas faire
roi reprend g7 et je fais deux
rencontres on au quai habran b3 tour
j'ai eu six sociaux le web en attendant
temps en temps le cap des 400 jeux et
des casinos étaient pourchassés mieux
mais là je suis peut-être gagnant non
feinte gagnant à gagner un tournoi
et en plus je vais peut-être le prendre
avec la tour en tour j'ai vite battu 3
sets en fait moi servir c'est pas mal
pour un 8 tours à huit
ça commence à prendre forme la fab une
nouvelle fois un bon il s'avoue pas
paniquer a tenté je vais faire tout
reprend ses 8,6 et 10,6 échanges un peu
quoi mais bon ouais c'est ça non mais
peu importe on descend
ces quatre c4 j'aime bien change aurait
fait ces quatre mots - temps un peu les
pions et tu vois ce qui se passe quand
on cliquait des six pales liquide
ouais mais la mythique pas quand cela ne
décourage peut-être temps des huit mois
ok ce sens pas grand chose mais ok ça va
sûrement tu vas faire 6 4 6 1 et c'est
plus que potentiellement c'est une peau
de banane que de l'apprendre alors là ça
va l échange
entendez pas de balade blessures à
reprendre de la tête obligeait les
échanges et montrer ce qu'on sait pas si
ça ouais finale de fous je suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit gagnante finale de vous
sait pas toujours les plus faciles à
gagner le fameux barrières légales
ouais alors peut-être 81 4 h 3 way en
session à temps l'âge et 4 à 3 sa gagne
pas au kenya roi f1 ouais de défraiement
bon que ça va encore mais là c'est plus
long on n'est plus très bien en fait non
c'est un des gars tu étais pas sûr non
plus que 33 oui car il fait froid c'est
6 3 des 5 ou quelque chose comme ça
c'est du coup du goût d'autres ont plus
gagné clément nous on était à trois nous
mêmes se libérer mon terroir chef rc6
sur cette même île de 6ème et x 7 mais
j'aime pas trop c't'histoire
si on prend b5 ses pages un petit je
regardais b45 db6 ouais c'est ça trois
témoins trois ans j'ai quatre ans après
mais bon quand bien même jeu que tu
aimes ça je sais pas b 3 c3 de trois
pions prendre trois ou quatre fois qu'on
met de voir poindre en salle une robe
angers 4 h à 12
c'est vrai ça une tête de truc alors ok
bon elle veut faire bref 5g gare
pourrait changer
alors pourquoi elle a fait autant de
coups avec sont fous ces droits trois
des six robes trop à tommy or nul n'est
pas au mieux non elle va la perdre
ce jeu c'est les deux me paraissait
incroyable
non mais là la panique en angleterre en
finale en fait elle perd en finale elle
arrive pas là pas les bons réflexes en
finale aujourd'hui
non mais tu vois quand on dit que à
moins 4 matches 1 6l craque pas facile
de gagner celle-là elle enfin été
gagnant que elle remonte à moins 2 ça
c'est vraiment le match des occasions
ratées
non non c'est tout le match comme ça
c'est un match qui est sous le signe de
la gaffe fabre s'est pas vraiment fait
ça tourne mal
ouais c'est ça c'est parce que oui si tu
mets juste les deux finales et on a deux
gagnantes qu'elle a perdu comme ça tu es
déjà à égalité bon après harry cas on a
raté une facile aussi un moment donné
deux parties mais mais tu pourrais être
ouais tu pourrais être à - 1 - 2 ce
serait au monde m'a volé le contenu des
partis pour un problème mais c'est
l'organisation el béchir
ouais vraiment elle joue pas mal sinon
mais c'est ouais c'est frustrant c'est
sur un dock ou quoi c'est sur un de
coûts que le match se joue lundi à toi
la fin des trois minutes là il reste 7
minutes disent oui donc on va arriver
peut-être c'est la dernière partie
suivant comment elle elle durant ces 2
milliards de après ces trente minutes de
bullet après le bullet ça peut tourner
un tu sais si tu as vu le match de paris
contre rennes space à rennes
il est sorti du bois mais bon il est
quand même assez dans le bois la wii
mais le truc c'est que le but let's et
des vagues ça peut si tu prends un rush
ça peut aller vite
tu peux vite en gagner deux trois
d'affilée le mec un peu tu vois donc
faux faut pas qu'elle craque un faux pas
qu'elle craque à -4 si elle pouvait
revenir à -3 ce serait bien sûr tout cas
de nouveau une position correcte les
commandes du lettres marib a apparemment
d'après le d'algorithmes elle est un peu
plus forte
mais bon c'est passé dans les transports
doux sans lesquels ces quatre lettres -
sinon la caisse 4 fait mal bon il peut
être qu'il des 4 ou quoi datacash trois
ans j'ai deux mois notamment messi 4e
d'un très logique que les quatre
français obligé les recettes mais ça a
l'air d'être correctement quand même
pour marie
maintenant voilà mais c'est toujours
l'histoire géo sur le football a
toujours le mauvais fout un peu plus une
option de finale ouais tu vois le
mauvais coup contre le vent fou c'est ça
je pourrais encore plus le fouet d'entre
eux thomas l'insa lecavalier
qui se fait chasser quand même elle va
pouvoir revenir en c 6e
[Musique]
c'est un peu chiant juste la fin du
monde mais simplement ouais c'est un peu
chiant parce que ça met les gaz et les
contreparties qui dit que arica défend
très bien savait qu'elle défend bien
je ne savais pas de peur de jouer des
coups aux siens je pense en mon nom mais
lui c'est dommage parce que c'était il
ya deux trois partis qui étaient
vraiment à la portée de marie et c'est
un autre jour elle les gagne pas ce que
je veux dire c'est ça c'est ça le truc
en fait c'est que c'est pas sur son
niveau de jeu ou quoi c'est juste
aujourd'hui il y en a deux trois qui il
ya deux trois parties qui tourne mal qui
tourne dans le mauvais sens et il ya la
confiance qui se perd et c'est sa nature
joue le même match demain peut-être
calais rappaz est excellent mais c'est
ça le but aujourd'hui c'est le jour
c'est les circonstances j'aime pas trop
évolution non plus je dis je pense que
ça va aller
kg 8 tu attends tu me frapper c'est un
grand jeu contrôlé par là que le nom
ça va aller t'inquiète pas ça va bien se
passer bien se passer
t'inquiète pas bonjour pas très inquiet
mais je sens je sens que tu t'inquiètes
pas ce que la marine est en train de se
préparer pour aller à colmar tu as f 6
ans mais ça va tenir ça va tenir c'est
c'était été robuste en mettre un
cavalier ou trois tenez regardez 5 et eu
à faire des trucs et tu vas jouer vite
et à la fin c'est juste horrible jeudi
par youri mais elle va tenir qu
objectivement c'est juste par un spécial
d'euros 30 je sais pas quoi mais j'évite
découlent je sais pas ce qu'elle veut
faire elle et h5 kaboom prendre l'espace
[Musique]
ben voilà allez hop
de maistre en bref les restaurants rage
et 6 en taux de défaut oui bon bah oui
nous parvenir votre un peu vive on est
généreux trois ayant 1,3 fin géronte
attend de pied ferme
prépare toi quoi mais on attend géré on
s'en fout fin j'ai ramé g entre 3 et
alors palmarès du cavalier ou trois je
suis route trois là je menace le tas de
viande et cinq gymnases marque à tout le
monde ouais pas très peur un joker en f
cell c'est très bien mais ce qui fait
qu'elle fait bon de même 3 je pense
turillon indemne de ce parc et 6
je comptais changent et changent si tu
fais ce que tu fais ce que tu veux juste
que le mps
ouais on échange si on prend des 500
apprentis change tout le ban voilà série
de coups le bail mais je vais faire je
vois pas comment tu as gagné sa base on
bat bat g de faire 5 chez thfr 4g fait
laurent 1,5
faut faire gaffe parce que sur ces 4
face à peu j'ai fait à saint cloud
builders
ouais c'est bien jouer au foot
franchement
bref aux 3,5
oui mais pas juste et humaine au final
deux fois là il se passe rien ouais un
peu un peu chiant en fait est un truc
qui s'est mal passé parce que fou peut
contourner
non mais c'est là sa part des 6 pouces
et 7 2 6 2 blancs ou les mois suivants
pour faire oublier une destination du
prothésiste eu elles réussissent
pourquoi n'est pas le fond 1 5 marie en
fait j'ai pas fais tu es cannes le x e 5
3 des 6 et c'est sûr reprend du terrain
quand même voilà je crois que je me dis
qu'il faut cinq maintenant oui parce que
tu vas prendre en tenaille mais fait le
truc barrois re 6 mai f5 maintenant
théâtre c'est impressionnant
j'ai pas trop compris ce qu'elles ont
fait ouais ça joue mais j'ose dire pour
le tracé perdant à l'échelle des
communes aussi c'est peut-être passé par
moss était gagnant le problème c'est que
tu peux pas faire [ __ ] en tracé
passait par un moment où c'était gagnant
non ouais c'est aussi la presse enfin
disons le deviennent de fou clairement
ça va bien maintenant
non c'est mais elle tourne à moins 5 du
coût
et ouais mais elle perd en finale mais
c'est plus par manque de temps bon enfin
on repart pour une pause d'accord de
sabine je vous invite pareil a dit les
mecs on est de retour dans un mythe pour
les boulettes
[Musique]
non donc les mecs on est reparti fav le
bullet c'est chaud c'est reparti fab
five non c'est pas partie faux départ
c'est génial qua non mais j'ai vu des
coups ça va se passer je suis chaud là
le plaid c'est mon moment préféré fab et
je suis très motivé enfin non autonomes
a les larmes montent à la donner du
coeur
allez quoi on y va on les défonce les
indiens on va en faire un petit un petit
curie quoi ça j'ai senti venir
à ce petit jeu ça va la suite mais où
est ce que je disais la dernière fois
c'est tu nous faut un curry on va te
font battre wattmètre un foie gras en
entrée
qu'est ce qui nous oppose les indiens en
termes culinaires comment tu peux te
battre il va demander un thé masala de
merde on va lui remettre
mais on te mets une bouteille de rouge
du bourgogne niveau de mettre à la scie
à la place ba voila le la cij le crash
ça m'intéresse pas on va y mettre du là
si tu sais ce que je remets j'ai envie
de l'armagnac 40 ans d'âge un nordmann à
tous ouais je te mets du 40 ans d'âge
toi tu fais quoi tu fais pas avec ton la
cie et on curie bas mais moi je sais pas
au bout d'un moment il va falloir parler
il va falloir un petit pot-au-feu tu as
on va vers des plats bien de chez nous
ça va faire très mal fab aller la
bouteille de rouge quoi aller à turin
nombre de cas vite mais du cassoulet
dans mes choix gère la gastro de la
gastronomie indienne en sueur ils ont
ils ont un plat palmarès palmarès on
fait du curry la choucroute ou madame
barry stein choucroute
tu fais quoi passer une choucroute je
sais pas c'est lourd s'impose encore by
je te jure des variantes choucroute de
la mer jeu coûte de la terre bah c'est
un rêve où il te faut couture y curie au
poulet courrier à la viande
sur une petite crevette caresser sa
sauce piquante taille mais bon ton cul
riz de la marche une choucroute de la
mer
si tu fais quoi maintenant la solution
que l'on peut faire d'autres choses
la mère des plateaux de fruits de mer
des huîtres des saint-jacques flambé
mais c'est un sens la calabre automne
aussi très haut bon allez fabre on est
parti alors je capte jacques de partout
l'oeuvre à l'ailé saint jacques on le 4
et des quatre on y va les mecs allée f
qu'adam des deux grands rock a les
boules et on n'est pas là aux vendanges
aller look rock locle le grand bain non
non elle et 1800 bullet élégance rixe
j'ai jamais vu ça les amis il y aller
jamais non mais elle joue jamais mais
voilà mais non mais pourquoi encore ce
fois çi ça pas marcher tout le match les
amis qu'est ce qui se passe à l'ebu une
cavalière cinq échecs qui arrivent peu à
peu à refonder une pièce en un à l'efap
dame madame g5 et dames g5 avec qui des
cavaliers h c'est un conte arnaque mais
sur la grille et prend rien allez à
l'étude âme ces trois allers les amis
allaient la dame qui vient on attaque
les pions boom j'en sais rien moi allez
tourbillon on y va vous évite qu'on fait
et je vous vite et bien mesdames c'est
bien c'est bien fait mal et un moment
donné on envoie les caïds et 2 kgs ckd
c'est bien on va mettre le pion en f3 on
va couper des oreilles du cavalier aller
tous les trois caisses et 4 allez vous
prendre en amont à le prendre un fou
voilà tu n'as plus de cavaliers sur n'a
plus qu'un nouveau surnom à un cavalier
contre cavaliers bon là ça c'est
égalisant fab
mhadjou vite lâché confiance frappe j'ai
confiance à l'est d'aden alors au tour
allez mon but 3 triste mais c'est pas
grave c'est pas triste
on est heureux f3 froid je crois voilà
bravo ça c'est bien allez ça va marcher
dessus la tension 2 h 4 h 5 va tous les
machins
ouais mais c'est pas grave on tient bien
on va mettre le cavalier de trois on la
laisse venir on est fourbe
on va la voir la fourrure ont valu cours
des prochaines années qui ont ces quatre
c'est bien un fab on attaque l'option
américain c'est bien les rouages de la
honte elle aura et courait en cours à
hussein allez vas-y i do rio ou trois
familiers
il y est il va y avoir f4 elle va se
faire défoncer arica elle est mal elle
est mal à les tours à aller voir c'est
bien ça tombe bien de ses dires des
oeuvres entre huit ans je sais pas
peut-être cabedo qui est des trois
maintenant bon os 4 était joué 5 minutes
par tous les pros 5 et brossac
c'est un tour de plus un ouais c'est un
pion c'est un pion simplon elle craque
elle craque arica c'est plus à rien ça
donc je leur apprends à dos tu au rwanda
mme rivasi on y va
j'avais trois des cinq matches aller
chaque échec et on répète pas trois fois
on ne répète pas la haye tour à ça c'est
bien allez allez bo son jeu de jambes
vous faites bien sûr les appuis quoi
bien comme il faut
allez on prend le pion à l'est l'option
il va gagner mais les échecs mais un
échec chez pas fabien deuxième échec roi
dessins que si les sapeurs hockey ou
trois sinon qu'il prend et on a
tellement je suis pas sûr sûr sûr c'est
qu'elle est en france et quatre masters
france et 4 mais bon je vais faire pour
ces six échecs rouaroua machin et
cavalli machin etc a eu lieu 3 à la
pause si ce nom une bombe nuls oui mais
bon enfin ok mais l'autre veut gagner à
léon là bas on l'a puni punit la punit
la roi ou trois cavaliers à 3 qui est
libéré et tu pues rien contre le roi
tapez donc allée des pions de partout
ouais pu ni la mairie ni page 4 bon mais
pensez que c'est changer ça finisse pas
grave
donc voilà c'est nul contre le pion b le
cavalier tient bien
on n'était pas loin femmes à vous la
montre non non elle son fair play les
fiancés franchement c'est fair play
jusqu'à maintenant les 266 points aux
parties à l'ets mari et trois ils
marient chaque aller 2-5 nommage un bain
[Musique]
ben on voit pas leur car mon avis elle
pourrait aller fragile indienne elle est
fragile
elle est fragile allaient ils doivent
d'étudiants d'anthologie très frêle quoi
elle est très frêle aller faut y aller
il faut y aller il marie un peu plus de
un peu plus d'impact la tour en des huit
la dame en d3a les ont rejoints au final
elle te refais des pires que de partout
en fait c'est tout à fait fou le pire
que moi mais bon la tâche trois oranges
de veau et fois je crois
ouais ça bonne nouvelle elle s'en prend
pions des trois cette fois ci est sûre
j'ai quatre c'est quoi l'idée est une p
4 peut-être peut-être québec à ne vous
prends des trois ou quatre oui c'est du
jeu bull et skt pour jouer à la bulle
est tu t'en vois une pièce et puis t'as
qu'à vous faire gagner peut-être de d4
un jour qui vont arriver dès que tout
ceci est un message qui n'est pas le
fait qu'elle ait db4 non bah je sais pas
comment ça marchait bien même ça
marchait pas du tout mais tu vois c'est
envoyer quoi les cavaliers 4 bref c'est
un cas les allées mari allait aller les
joueuses françaises là qui est bien en
bessin un boom chasse moi ce cavalier ou
à les chasselas de partout poussent là
en dehors de l'échiquier je ne veux pas
je ne veux plus voir une pièce fab une
pièce blanche sur cet échiquier aller ça
dégage on envoie tout re un aller et
boum mais une tour sur la première année
non pas les défendre et qu'ils allaient
en dessin qui nous reste est super
n'hésitez pas de chance d'être bon et la
sai on retouche ou quoi là on fait 5 ans
prochain on dégage cette dame-là jour de
voir ça inquiète en échange thoune en
trinquet dégâts allez on a le réseau
l'époux et monjeza un cahier vous allez
on envoie à fabas les femmes ne soient
pas toi qui joues quand j'aurai
confiance soit je serai sûr que tu
enverrait bas il faut quoi en fait ce
serait en retard au temps et puis dans
le jeu des finales des machins qui a été
aidé supérieur quoi dans les parties
avant donc en route et domine dans un
compartiment d'essayer autre chose mais
peut-être des 4 1 on va prendre à deux
et puis on se barre zaki a les photos
envoyées là il faut faire quelque chose
mari allait mari voilà c'est comme le
festival des pions des purs isolé sur
blanc le lieu des petits îlots par ci
par là ça va pas trop la fab
on va pas se le cacher on va pas se
mentir vous allez c'est une bonne
nouvelle c'est une bonne nouvelle femme
elle a pris le pion à l'est d'amiens
voilà c'est ça qu'on veut voir marie
découvert en avant s'est découvert
l'avant ça d'un coup vers l'avant mais
pas deux annonce très bien on prend à
deux ans mais n'a toujours pas sans mal
c'est pas moins de sept étages 5 non
c'est horrible il ya tout qui tombe fab
bien tous les jours on sait de son
[Musique]
chiffre encore mystic c'est pas le pire
moment pour que ça arrive on va dire ça
comme ça on va se rassurer c'est vrai
que bon on est bien mal dans le match
bah on est mal on est mal on manque qu
on manque un peu d'impact d'impact
physique j'ai envie de te dire je rate
les plaquages
ouais on rate des plaquages c'est ça
allait l'afo front prend un rouge ont
fait un plaquage cathédrale on se
réveille toi attendait son mari elle
joue contre pauline dimitro âge ou
quelqu'un d'autre
assez génial mais c'est bon ils ont
conclu un nul et la partie jeu votre ami
de 200
dmitro un ukrainien le bania d'or avait
pas loin mari elle est pas loin mais
nouvelle fois ils ont compté ni way et
là ça c'était y'a la pendue qui tourne à
l'est larbitre il faut arrêter le temps
ouais je la monte l'a fait semblant
d'être blessés arica elle a rien elle a
rien fab
j'espère faire du temps additionnel à la
fin et bien sûr bien sûr il faut revenir
avec le panneau quoi minimum quatre
minutes pour ce match va aller un plan
efficace ou un truc comme sourds qui va
te casse devant le bénin et on pousse
tous mais on en voit c'est ça qu'il faut
faire dans l'hudson on va se faire
tomber ça qu'on s'en fiche à l'élève 3g
4g a tous voila voila voila enfin que
c'est un tournant du match là c'est un
tournant ça un tournant là ça peut
tourner fab eux deux qui essaient ainsi
jamais on défend et g4 de l'autre
connaît tous la vente partout et après
on en voit mais c'est la vérité les amis
bon je le fond d'être en fait n'est ce
pas il est là il a le mérite d'être la
femme en mousse un kilo sans manger et
h4 chabris capte tout cela pique mes
infos schiste bien voilà vous on veut
faire h 4 h 5 voire la colonne h matip
allez on va aller mal traîné ses bons et
htc magic a dit m tu apprends b4 c'est
bien c'est un pion c'est dans sa
jeunesse carpet
ouais 17 p 3 voilà dégage et on va
revenir éclats d'amandes et quatre
peut-être un jour aller h4 qui est parti
fâché 4g 4 et h5 après allégé 4 c'est le
moment checa je comprends h5
on a su si jamais ce que tu prends
est-ce que tu as tu prends et huet à
tours angers 1
j'éprouve kg 3 et allié clé 3g prend il
n'y a rien donc la preuve crois quoi on
vous mater ce roi noir à les épreuves
sont allégées en cas d'orage de palalda
caruana tombé de mes 2 allez c'est bien
mais je voulais soit nous qui mathieu
ont quoi pas d'acompte défendre ce droit
akalé qu'au prochain quand même c'est un
peu comme dans creed quoi tu as tu fou à
quel point contre vous on ne sait pas si
ça marche qu'on en voie de prendre la
bande am moment où la petite fille n'a
plus en plus quand même ce qui n'est pas
non plus très grave qu'elle était proche
de 5
prends moi ce pion e5 que je me sens le
devoir prend le on s'en fout traqué mais
le juge par ce projet dans ces trois ça
fout le savoir mon production pas de toi
moi ces deux sa razzia des droits des
deux conflits d'aujourd'hui on adoucit
conclu cela dans le monde
on est bien on prend donc encore temps
de 5 mais tu n'as plus pions qu'on voit
les tours est fan on échange ses entours
fr c'est bien fait pour g2 et on pousse
on fait tout rejet limité mais fuit je
crois que peter nous avons avec deux
rangées ans cache un bon le truc c'est
dire on n'a pas laissé bien faut prendre
on propose un club prêt à laisser bien
plus ample à l'ifab à l'ifab ses parois
des quatre noms qui en a le temps à 14
secondes et on en trouve dangereux par
coup on a super le temps là là on n'est
pas pressé on peut les faire les choses
bien comme il faut
allez petit pas et là des familles
liquide 4 twh 5 maintenant à l'éclair
arriver c'est bien allez c'est bon et au
rejet le prince william
et oui on a gagné le grand roque on l'a
dit depuis le début qu'il fallait le
faire fab
voilà et ça y est c'est parti c'est par
un an
elle rejoindra mauvais wagon à la haye à
yahya yahya il est mauvais mec qui qui
nous gêne dans ce match fab vu que
j'avais sans dire c'est les indiens guy
jeu de je ne sais mais c'est un an dire
quand même il est masqué mais ça n'a
filtré il essaye de faire parce qu'il a
plus beaucoup de temps femme à avoir
coché trois noms mais faut qu'elle joue
l'attaqué elle joue bien elle attaque l
attaque bien marri ses positions là elle
a eu du mal à rica mais elle est un peu
long tariqa thurella marielle de la
réussi à jouer plus vite et tout ça on
sent femme dans ce section de bullet que
mari était au dessus aujourd'hui papa a
pas aujourd'hui la madrague d'un âge
sont pas en avant fab on sent que marié
plus forte à la marque il faut bien que
le parti du progrès faits par damas cinq
à aller là bas cinq garages 5 ou 3 8 pc
hp annonce qu'on s'en fout des coups des
coups je vis très bien avec des singles
à l'e-book fab fab les cinq bons jeux
jouables au tchad
10h10 quoi bon je sais plus non mais
elle est bien là marie une nouvelle fois
regarde comment ils marchent dessus
cav a lieu cinq bouts monde attaque
tadam allez on va attaquer des pions
toussaint par un aller retour ces huit
maintenant on s'en prend voilà c'est
bien ça on que le fourneau comme ses
théâtres
allez allez les amis elle va elle va
remonter la marie ont besoin de la
castille cinq cantons romain dream
cavaliers en 17 6 1 leclerc aussi si on
ne veut pas le voir descendre
on peut tout faire femmes on peut tout
faire le nom remontée que kelly verser 5
allons repartir parce qu'on veut est
vite allé accélère marie c'est quand
accéléré que ça a bien marché et
peut-être
et peut-être des g5 aussi possible qui
semble pas des coupes au monde s'en fout
et 4 est dans le dur la marie ses
positions elle a du mal hein c'est pas
l'argent prend tout prend b5
si on prend dames 7 s'est bien amusé
c'est toi et non mais c'est cool elle va
pouvoir récupérer
ok tu apprends des systèmes français en
moins voilées jacques de penser à un
double tour son coin arranger ça doit ça
devrait adorer de faire face encore la
vitrine on l a bien joué elle joue bien
la mari elle m'a ce tour c'est de vous
prouver ce à quoi nos proches de
maintenant et fou prend b5 tromso
comprend les cinq raté pour ces cinq
années ça mais attention ce cas le pion
des qui peut partir de l'autre côté
mettons pas en bessin que c'est jouable
c'est dommage qu'elle ait raté fou prend
ouais ok mais ça soit là pour apprendre
et ce n'était pas évident mais le roi
autour d un epci f6 braille fitr est au
tour des séries
c'est vrai que c'est bon c'était un
mystique je pense je pense se bat b 5
web et 5 mes5 sa fille de sa tour sa c5
pousse on pousse on pousse c'est facile
hein normalement à la brède auront à
dire c'est que normalement ça devrait
aller fab bâton c'est quand même la voix
l'a pas découvert donc du coup alors
très bien c'est tourache un bon ménage
qui a fait tourner la pompe d'une
attention
ouais c'est c'est de bonne guerre pour
mon coeur j'essai hockey exemple ça
gagne les deux de suite aller il y aura
que quatre points d'écart allégé fbf
pour prendre contre 120 en compte ou
fair play a ri car elle est arrivée en
abandonne la voilà c'est bien bravo
allez un peu de fair play du côté indien
ça fait plaisir
soit faire payer jusqu'au
quand on pourra te mettre un couteau un
coup de couteau dans le dos on le fera
ne t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas ça va
bien se passer bien se passer
t'inquiète pas citer site est déconnecté
ou tu fermes explique on ne donnera pas
de nul hein ça faut le savoir aller à la
recul maintenant elle nous fait elle
elle fait une reculade à elle fait une
reculade à une alexina lesquels pro f
cell boom structure que le cal
affectionne écoute ça va bien se passer
à mon avis bien se passer
je sais qu'ici quatre ans des deux
femmes je sens la remonte à la que tu
l'as en arrive je suis pas trop aller
fab la schl ou une info tu sens la
remonte à bari bon on encore la femme
dit le mais c'est encore aller il veut
pas dire qu'il veut pas le lâcher l'info
qu'ils s'en aillent montana c'est une
info qui lui cache pour le moment bon
allez c'est clair que les à 3 c'est bien
on va rebondir et on n'est pas mieux
mais on se bat n'en est pas moins bien
aussi peut-être un poil mais ça n'en ait
mis autant femmes resteront n'est caché
ses assaillants n'est plus ou moins bien
on est de retour ici
fab on est on est mieux autant aller
qu'ils nomment ces deux on se cache à
quatre nous même pas les femmes autour
des 1,4
c'est bien elle joue plus vite la mari
elle est vraiment dans la partie elle
reprend ses quatre le pion c6 est faible
fab ont le droit comme le site s'appuie
sur la case des cinq je pense même
aimons la lgv à s'activer elle va
s'appuyer sur rien du tout à la g35
aller fois s'attaque à l'abondance est
bien un coup une menace une autre
expression des sites et des six
cavaliers décide fait le vas-y non le
voit
ah mais non merci elle le voit pas
femmes au nom au nom au non c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible et des six
était la fourchette
c'était la fourchette comment l a pas vu
comment elle a pas vu comment elle l'a
pas vu fab à l'occasion en or
aulas c'est incroyable papa tu vois un
match que vous voyez que c'est attention
il a déconné et là c'est fini fin et des
seuls frais je crois quoi bon je sais
pas et on peut encore sauver gm sans
qu'on a des pièces mal mise et que trois
ont fait mais bon ça c'est rien faire
n'importe quoi tu veux mais quel dommage
ce qui est des six qui tendait les bras
fab
on perd sur des fourchettes quoi ce
match se joue sur des fourchettes
non ce fait nul
il reste évidemment toujours encore en
cas de bon aloi gagner la norme vesa
malades ou qui jouent là
armand 05 05 2010 on voit tous ces gens
qui ne se voyaient fab
je suis dégoûté fable à de la fourchette
bud adams minutes apparemment c'est show
est fini 35e faux voulu gagner mais nos
filles ça fait trois points ça peut
faire quatre parties suivant non mais
bon on est tous les mecs sont glissés
jeudi
je crois que la question ps marie je
vois le truc tout rouge vrai ne joue pas
ouais y'a plus de connexions bon c'est
peut-être la fin des haricots
ainsi la connection en tout cas les 20
secondes perdues ouais on dit que ça
doit être mort s avec les parties
dansées un peu plus de trois minutes la
partie un bon là
des pertes de temps à diego armando et
tout ça que sont des jouets venant du
rajout non ouais ouais mais bon bon
j'avoue gagner tout au plus on verra
plus on fait un scandale par mais il y
aura que trois pas tout les
conditionnels il y aura rien à ccc cruel
femme parce que parce qu'il ya la
fourchette lie à la fourchette la ja non
j'ai beaucoup de projets web au coup de
fourchette et à l'impression qu'elle est
si proche et puis russie les choix dont
l'ouverture qui était peut-être un petit
peu un petit peu
même dommage de ne pas avoir joué comme
ça avant a dit que ça va mieux marcher
mais au moins tu change la dynamique des
choses et fonction prend une tour ont
vite on échangera et fiable à la
pression tous les pions s'est pas encore
fini mais ça c'est rien on peut encore
rêver fab rêvons plus grands ce que ça
marche je n'avais plus goût ça dépendra
des mois à riga qui rêve qui rêvent ses
rêves plus grands aussi alors je me
demande ce que ça donnera en demi finale
face à dany année dans le tableau de
bord danielian qui avait été assez
impressionnante
tiens way qui avaient bien défendu on
verra ce que ce que ça donne contre le
braqueur dans ce match on se faufile est
encore bien à la dame c'est dommage car
on se faufile encore ailleurs je pense
par les méga faut faire du yatenga qu'il
a qui est des quatre places à temps
ouais mais yatenga qui tour à deux mais
on espère aller c'est pas parce qu'il
prend b5 food et quatre pouces et 4 je
sais pas si cette tour peut rester en
vie ici un arrêt en doute bull a laissé
bien à laymont fabia peut-être tourbe et
8 es fou b4 ouais mais bon coup sûr pour
tout juste 32 avait foudroyés fuite ou
être mangé deux ouvrages un retard que
j'ai trouvé chez f my way qu'est-ce que
vous êtes champion belge attend
paris-tours b2c bien rangée san je pense
qu'avec le jeu vous des cinq fours et
cinq femmes a très bien fait ça fout des
cinq maintenant c'est damien on est
tombé un ouais on peut faire trembler
nourrir 6 il ya le fouet juste cette
tourbe et nyse sny en fait pour fou des
6es la caf est fou des cinq échecs
l'intro de six ans d'études retient
toujours le choc on peut la menthe et
opera et la bataille
yes yes yes fab le mat le mat il est
venu le mat il est venu femmes on est
récompensés on est récompensé on revient
à moins 3 allez il reste encore un peu
de jeu par quand il faudrait que le
grand jeu le grand rodez et on est
revenus fable on est dans le match
encore qu'est ce que c'est que m on veut
legrand dans comme on veut de projets
gars allez on voit grand roque allez on
voit grand roque a laissé bien elle te
provoquant c'est pas fameux cavaliers 2
h 4 quand même en faisait pas vrai mais
il y aura du h4
allez on vous à marie mais je peux
lancer qu'annoncé 4 avril à fayence et
4h 3 assez mou du ccc c'est mou du genou
ça peut ressembler une espagnole fab un
peu que tu affectionnes pourquoi prendre
j'aurais quand même pris en 5 plutôt à
donner moins de monde au choix bah ouais
non oui à la prochaine mais attends peut
pas faire dante un cavalier prend 1 et
b5 gimont ok mais ça c'est pas mal aussi
peut-être attend ça donne quoi femmes en
inde une bonne qualité bah c'est bien un
pion s'est bien rendue en iran à la
foulée six mois tu peux faire te réfères
fous ces cinq ans premier peut-être
orale selon vous devez mieux l'idée
m'est venue si j'aime bien si tu prends
quelques jours en baisse 4 et tu étais
d'audience m
ah les marchands plus intéressant qu'on
allait la marche à blanc fait un truc
vendredi fait le portail qui supprime
bran ou et bran ou et le bran de la
position avec les idées deux peut-être
un grand centre fab
on voit le calice jusqu'à la lie
histoire muslim une déconnexion entre
très fair play
non mais là c'est la semaine pour moi
mais c'est dommage parce que je crois
que ce match est perdu sur des décisions
d'ouverture
ouais sur les fourchettes et sur les
fourchettes fab c'est dur à ce qu'ils
avaient envie encore une nouvelle fois
un joueur français l'imminence pitch scr
ça devient quand même une habitude
peut-être moi qui ait plus de joueurs
français
ben je sais pas vla de revient platz où
nous parce que génial bête qui vient
jouer le speech est féminin oui moi j'ai
le droit
bordel j'ai le droit à l'erreur mais
c'est dur voilà ces dernières parties
mais j'ai envie de dire anecdotique
ouais c'est dommage c'est dommage
dans le chat j'espère vous n'êtes pas
trop déçu que c'est pas la défaite à
d'abord abattu
j'en profite pour dire que demain on
commentera avec maxime vachier lagrave
soi quand on est jeune ce sera à wailly
contre prague allende à bago au
mourillon bas mon avis on peut vivre des
adoptions demain ça peut adopter
je dis ça je dis rien mais c'est pas mon
bleu vent comme étant le gros match
machin va moi je vois surtout un mec à
25,30 qui est pas très bon en blitz
contre un des meilleurs joueurs du monde
non mais chez bord me vengera comme
fringale en date réforma je veux juste
un mec qui va se faire défoncer perso
mais non mais je demande qu à me tromper
mais on m'explique que c'est
génial comme match que prague allende à
un bon j'étais bien battu on pousse les
sauts je sais pas où
oui oui femme tellement c'était trop
quatre parties s'étaient pas en trois
heures par an devant ça comme étant un
match exceptionnel écoute je demande qu
à me tromper un nom que tu te mets 2 3
doutre moi je pense que s'il fait si
peur de 10 points je pense que
l'handicap disent tu vois je prends
quand même vous ai dit tu vois à la rate
et cavalia si cela est peut-être à
waimes et 5 nuits en fait oui c'est vrai
que ça fait longtemps qu'on le voit donc
l'argent comptant oui il ne sera jamais
champion du monde je dis ouais comme
beaucoup des joueurs chinois pour nous
en parle beaucoup mais ne verse jamais
25 ans a dit non
il sera jamais champion du monde mais
n'en attendait beaucoup de lui mais ça
donne beaucoup zana tout ça mais en fait
ça va il est la même et on vous l'a de
la battue en indonésie guy qui profite à
perdre s'ils ne l'a pas battue on croit
que si c'était pas trop le choix d'un
dessin 13 au piquet rocchi dit au moins
mari a eu le mérite d'être en quart de
finale contrairement aux françaises de
roland garros qui n'ont pas passé second
tour ouais mais le truc c'est que
commence en croire vous commencez en
carembault le mérite soit eh bien je
dois repartir sur le stream en anglais
je vais faire un raid sur la chaîne en
anglais pour pour faire une interview de
marie fin pour traduire non je suis
parti à tembo a pris un coup itunes a
tous je vis en fait de toute façon ça va
être cette brutale quoi
ouais en fait je vais faire un raid sur
la chaîne en fait ça va arrêter notre
strict en fait comme ça tu seras 3 il en
reste une belle interview
c'est une interview aux échos plus un
nom et je vois traduire ce que vont dire
ce pico et anna rudolf je vais te dire
que ça me ça m'enchante pas vraiment en
fait
quand je peins se trouve mon autre chose
mais là il évoque arlon vie civique qui
nous disent je même vision du check
point com et l'audio but faire on pense
est un très bon compromis à karlovic qui
a assez malin mais je le prends comme
toujours quand les gens regardent mon
stream de mettre la vidéo de beauté est
intéressant est que l'audio vos bombes à
la main c'est bien l'arrivée blanche où
c'est un très bon jour d'ouverture
les pions a changé dans son parti non
mais c'est suis un peu déçu à fabre j'ai
vu la tête qu'elle a pu quoi aller le 5
et précise ce projet si ça marche pas ça
marche pas pas perdu on s'amuse mais ça
marche plus on a quelques idées changé
si ce n'est noir ont mis en place la
défense rugueuse qui met 21 10 janvier
tu peux rien faire ceci c'est
complètement interdite lors stratégie
anti jeu centrale enfin au clonage ou ça
que peut-on faire
d'ailleurs ma réflexion qu'allonger de
comprendre c'est la déception
fab c'est la déception dallas alors sur
toi pour le veau pour l'interview non
mais l'interview j'aime pas trop
traduire du front s'allonger pas
traduire en fait les gens en audio ça
m'énerve en fait tous les propres
questions c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident tu vois enfin c'est un métier en
fait de faire ça c'est pas facile
toujours est il se rebelle pas de ce que
les gens ont dit non mais ça dépend sa
question est longue ou courte
ah oui et puis et puis
je vous conseille une carrière à l'année
seulement mon fort mais c'est dur en
fait c'est vraiment dur à faire 10 ans 3
delson bien se passer d'un parti ouais
lui dit il faut que je fasse comme la
doit au lieu de répéter avec l'adil
inventent des trucs c'est génial
question fatale à 10 ans remonte les
questionnaires entre les réponses et que
c'est extraordinaire
petit soulevé au taux attendu j'avais
fait ça à mon mariage en fait quand les
gens faisait des taux ce qui irait
d'yvan banon en fait ils trajet pas du
tout cas il faut des ses propres photos
ce que c'était extraordinaire se
disaient ses propres trucs qua non n'y a
que moi qui comprenait vraiment du coup
puisque à ce retard est commun qui
parlait couramment les deux langues mais
en fait je m'en foutais complètement ça
faisait marrer tu vois et les gens ont
mis à un certain moment à comprendre
clairement des mecs mais en fait c'est
pas possible qu'ils rigolent ils
traduisent pas du tout et la wla d'or
répond oui mais je rajoute un peu des
épices et c'est génial
hinse pour te mange tout ça allait le
mettre à la fin ça va gagner ça reprend
tous les pions du booking peu avant 6
heures je suis retombé huit échecs on
première c'est un cas très peu j'adore
comment tu as tu es quoi
farewell schiste pour notre schipman
bomba nul bah voilà bonne chance mon
interview
merci bon match demain dans le choc du
speech est junior
ouais ouais je passe le bonjour de tapas
voilà gilles fabien est servi à diviser
ce qui attend ça relou c'est génial mais
ce jeu pour un drop et la tchétchénie
est restée hors finales
score final 15 15 15 15 10 5 points
d'écart
ok bon ben beau match et donc les demi
finales sera le 20 et 20 les 20 et 25
juin avec arica contre danielian qui
sera un match très indécis
je pense très très ici d'avoir un favori
aygün inakosti nuke qui paie à monde
pour moi la finale avant l'heure c'est
vraiment les deux jouer si on fait la
plus forte impression
on verra ce que ça donne après rien
n'est fait dans ce pitch féminin femmes
ouais lui en france un bon bateau même
s'ils ont tous je te tiens tiens et gens
voient leur aide pour l'interview le
contrat je suis garde femme de minutes
le temps de talent est parti on est
partis avec leur aide